I didn't realize how good your hair is.
Thanks.
I'm losing it,
but it's what's left of it is still
rolling.
Right?
And we're live.
Gentlemen.
Hello Sean.
Hey,
how are you?
Hello Tom.
Hello?
Joseph.
Let's go.
You guys did a movie.
Did you make a movie?
We made a movie.
Did you guys do movies?
We do.
We're both the guys.
How many movies have you made?
A one.
Well,
I bet you've made it.
How many of you made before?
Uh,
I like six,
but yeah,
but we've made one.
We've made one.
What's your favorite one?
Other than the one that's right now?
Which is definitely a favorite because
you're promoting it right now.
A sex drive.
Sex drive is the one that nobody knows
about.
This first one,
nobody knows about it.
I mean it just,
it was one of those movies that just
opened a.
nobody knew about it,
but it was a,
it was a really,
really fun movie.
Maybe we can change that.
It's on itunes or Netflix.
Yeah.
It's all.
Are James Marston's in it?
This is the one.
Is this one that you like when you made
it?
You're like,
and maybe I'll go back to work in
fucking construction or whatever.
Yeah.
So I thought,
uh,
I thought it was over after that.
Did you finance it or anything?
No,
no,
we made it.
We made it with summit pictures and it
was,
it was,
it was amazing.
They,
they,
uh,
we were in town trying to get a career
going,
you know,
trying to try and make things happen.
We were making a TV pilot at the time
which was living hell and uh,
and we had gone out and pitch this idea
to a bunch of places and nobody bought
it.
So then in the middle of our,
uh,
editing our pilot summit pictures called
and said,
um,
we really,
we keep thinking about that pitch.
Would you guys be willing to write it?
And I said,
you know what?
I tell them I was really busy.
I said,
tell him I'll write it if I can direct
it,
but I figured that would make them go
away.
And they said,
all right.
And so we went in and we wrote it and we
turned it in and they green lit it.
It was this crazy,
it was just this crazy process where we
got this movie greenlit and I think we
wrote the draft,
you know,
in like a month,
and we turned it in and they loved it
and they said about it's a,
it's a,
it's a teen road trip movie.
It's about this,
these kids that,
uh,
it was kind of in the early days of the,
you know,
facebook and all that stuff and it
might've even been,
I don't know,
I can never track the,
it might've even been like sort of my
space into facebook that era,
you know,
um,
but it was about a kid who meets a girl
online and goes to lose his virginity
on,
on a road trip.
It's funny.
It is funny.
Yeah.
Meyerson's in it.
James Morrison and he was really funny,
uh,
Clark Duke and um,
and I had a good cast and there it is.
Yeah.
Wow.
Good.
Um,
but it was a really great experience.
It was really fun.
And then we,
we,
we tested it,
we did the test screenings and it just
murdered,
like,
it just in the studio got really
excited.
And I thought,
oh my God,
like I'm going to have a huge career.
And then movie came out and do not do
any business at all.
I was like,
okay,
I'm going to go back to Wisconsin and,
and uh,
not have a career at all.
So is it true that instant family you
hired Tom Because Bert Kreischer wasn't
available?
Yes.
God Damn it.
Don't tell me that man,
that's what I'd heard.
Well,
and he was asking,
he was asking for a lot of money,
a lot more within where it is lofty
with.
He's like,
Mark's gets,
I want double what they were like,
we can't do it.
So this movie is based in,
uh,
in no small part on your own life
experiences.
It is adopting an actual,
you adopted like a full family and three
of them in children.
But how wild.
That's a,
that's a bold maneuver,
sir.
What were the ages?
Six.
Three and a year and a half.
And Wow,
what was the process?
Um,
well it starts,
and this is how it starts in the movie
as well.
My wife and I,
for years,
I didn't,
I wasn't making any money including
after I made sex drive and um,
I,
uh,
so I didn't really feel like I could
afford to have kids.
So whenever we talk about it I just be
like,
no,
not there yet.
And uh,
and then finally,
um,
when I felt like I was doing better,
I was starting to get a career together.
I just started to feel like I was going
to be one of those old dads,
you know,
like by the time the kid was a teenager,
I wasn't going to be able to play with
the,
you know,
I'm 49 now.
I was 41 at the time.
And uh,
so God,
is that right?
Oh man,
it's depressing.
Anyway,
uh,
so I,
I,
uh,
I made this dumb joke to my wife.
I said,
look,
why don't we just adopt a five-year-old?
It'll be like I got started five years
ago and I'm like,
I'm right back in the game.
And she was like,
you know,
that's actually a really interesting
idea.
And I was like,
no,
I'm totally kidding.
Didn't mean anything by that.
At all,
and,
and then she went to a website and she
showed me the website and then when I
saw the website I was like,
Oh wow,
you see these kids,
you see their faces,
you start to learn a little bit more
about it.
And we just started having conversations
and it,
it went from there.
Now now I've got three kids and a movie.
And they're all siblings.
Yes.
So they're all came from one mom.
And would the,
what is,
how did they get separated from the
family?
Um,
I don't have a lot of details about
that,
you know,
they don't really tell you,
a little bit,
but not much.
I mean I know that there was,
that,
there were issues with drugs and,
and I think there was some kind of a
fire at some point,
but it's all pretty,
pretty sketchy as far as what you hear.
So you've learned a lot about the kids
themselves,
but not that much about the situation.
And what,
what made you want to turn this into a
film?
Like I would imagine that's a very
personal experience.
Yeah.
Um,
it was actually my writing partner,
John Morris,
because I had been about three years
into it at that point and the beginning
of it was a nightmare,
like,
like epic,
bad decision.
Why did we ever do this?
Yeah,
it was,
it was really a nightmare for a short
time.
And then when it came online and we
became a family,
it really became the best thing that
ever happened to me.
And you know,
when John and I get together every day,
we just talk about our lives a little
bit.
That's how we get started.
So John had been hearing all these
stories and one day he just said,
I don't know why we're not doing a movie
about this because nobody really knows
how this works when you go into foster
care to adopt kids.
So we started talking about it and then
there was the conversation of whether it
could be a comedy or not because that's
what we do.
We make comedies.
And John again was like,
most of the stuff you've told me is
really funny.
So not all of it,
of course,
but that's.
And then we thought,
wow,
we could approach this as a comedy and
we might be able to get,
you know,
a more general audience to get their,
their interest in it that way because
it'll feel less scary because that's the
problem is that most movies that are
made on this topic just frightened
people and they make people think that
these kids are all,
are all damaged and reachable anything,
you know?
Do you worry that it'd be like that
movie 101 Dalmatians at a bunch of
people start getting foster kids now and
screw them up?
Yeah,
we.
Well we were talking about top gun about
how,
you know,
remember when top gun came out and
everybody joined the navy thinking they
were going to fly the plane.
Well when the color of money came out,
pool halls boomed across the country.
I made a giant impact on pool halls for
that one tom cruise movie.
And it's just really a lot of people
just got scammed out of their fucking
pocket money.
Some of that going on.
I think the crazy thing about this too
was that like on the set,
you realize like when you were doing
this,
you go like,
Oh yeah,
I always thought of people who do that.
Like you know,
they exist,
but you're like,
those are nameless,
faceless angels.
They're not real people like you or like
do any of your friends at top.
I'd be like,
Oh,
don't not friends like that.
Those are other people you know.
And then you start like on the set there
was,
you know,
people visiting or consulting and there
would be like,
oh,
you know,
they adopted are they run some foster
care thing?
And then you're like,
oh this is actually something that
people really do.
Well.
Even like dudes on the crew that
somebody would come up,
you know,
who's in the electrical department,
be like,
oh hey bro,
I got,
I adopted two kids by the way,
if you're like really,
you know,
or hey,
I got adopted when I was four years old.
He just would like,
once you see it now,
everywhere people are hitting me up.
Someone hit me up yesterday like my
sister is adopting four siblings this
week.
Wow.
Yeah.
This is nuts.
I mean like it's like something I don't
want to.
It's almost like when your friend gets a
car and then you start seeing it
everywhere.
There's exactly like that though.
We talked about that video that went
around online of this little girl that
realize that she's opening up a box and
there's something in it that tells her
that she's been adopted by these two
people that are with her and it's
really.
Yeah.
It's impossible to not cry.
I mean if you have any heart at all and
you watch that little girl freakout and
it's breaks you up.
I think that's almost the test as far as
what you were talking about about how.
Because believe me,
I tested if you're a piece of shit or
when you watch that,
we should show that.
What's your reaction to.
Oh,
you're a piece of shit.
Sociopath.
Yeah.
But no,
I mean there that what you were just
getting at as far as,
believe me,
I'm not that guy that like,
I didn't feel special or like any one of
those sort of heart of gold angels,
you know,
we have a line that's in the movie where
mark just says that's the kind of people
that volunteer when it's not even a
holiday.
And we don't do that.
Yeah,
you should probably tell the audience
that I'm not staring in this movie right
now for people who know those people are
like.
So Tom Starts.
This is Mark Wahlberg movie for like
four and a half minutes.
There you go.
Mark Wahlberg.
Stars in the rest of it.
That's true.
That's a good way of breaking it down.
It was only probably like 90 minutes.
That's pretty good.
That's not bad.
Probably like seven scenes.
That's good scenes.
Now you've got a solid presence.
You didn't make the poster,
the poster,
the poster.
You made the standee though.
Did you know that there's a standee in
movie theaters in your and that.
Oh really?
Alright,
I'll take that one.
Heard that word.
Standee Sandy.
Those are the big cardboard,
those things where I didn't know that
either.
Cardboard cut out thing.
That's what I always call it cardboard
cutout.
Standee is the real.
The real term,
is that the term in the industry?
So yeah,
that's an industry term.
That's a real industry term.
You learned something today.
Wait,
so you.
Because you were telling me this and I
was like,
he was about to tell me before you came
in.
I was like,
this sounds like this could be pretty
good.
Don't tell me save it for the podcast
that because he's done this is the most
press sean's done for a film that he's
put out that.
Did you go under?
They were like,
let's give you some advice on media.
Yeah.
Well first of all,
I'm terrible at it,
so there's that because I don't do.
This is the thing when you direct a
movie,
especially movies like the kind of
movies that I make comedies and you
know,
big broad comedies,
people don't really care who directed
those movies and I'm good with that.
Like I'm totally good with that.
But what usually happens is the studio,
the director usually wants to be kind of
a part of the campaign so the studio
will find,
they'll sort of throw bones at u of a
press that you can do and I always tell
them,
look,
if I can be helpful in any way,
let me know.
I'll do whatever you need me to do,
but don't throw many bones because I
don't care.
Like I don't need to do that to kind
just pump up the ego of the director
that certain directors just really want
to be the next Quentin Terica.
Yeah.
I can't imagine there's some directors
they really have to do it for.
I get it.
They don't want you to feel left out or
whatever.
But by my first couple of movies I
thought,
Oh,
I have to do this stuff.
And then I realized I actually had this
experience where I was in this red
carpet thing and they brought me up to
this reporter and they said,
this is Shawn Andrews.
He directed the movie and she had this
big look on her face.
And then she went and I was like,
Nah,
it's cool,
you don't have to.
So disappointed.
And that's when it sunk into me where I
was just like,
oh,
they don't care.
They don't give it.
So that's,
that's fine with me.
I'm good there.
Well there's such fame whores and those
days are those red carpet things.
There are so weird.
Yeah.
Those things are so weird.
And some people that is the highlight of
their life walking the carpet.
I can't over here Tom.
You're posedown right?
It's a really weird thing.
Also pop.
See at the airport you have that where
um,
I've seen them where I'm at,
baggage and they're looking around and
then they're like,
hey tom.
And they'll ask me like,
what are things?
They're obviously not there for me,
but they're like,
they're like,
we got time till fucking whatever.
Seth rogen gets off the plane.
So let me ask you something.
And then they're like,
oh,
all right,
nevermind.
Here's everybody like,
just blow you off and you're like,
I happen only one time because this
obviously doesn't happen to me.
That was flying into lax and I was
getting off a red eye and I was so just
tired.
I looked like shit and that,
and this guy,
these two guys come up and they just
were so nice.
They were like,
Hey,
you're Shawn Andrews.
Right?
And I was like,
yeah,
yes I am on editors.
They nobody ever,
you know,
and so it takes me a second to realize
and I thought it was so weird because
they were,
it was right after,
it was shortly after daddy's home and
that was like the biggest hit and they
were asking me about horrible bosses too
and I was like,
why are they asking me about,
of all things.
And I thought,
oh,
because Jennifer Aniston's in it.
So they want me to say something about
Jennifer Aniston and just see if they
can catch me saying something crazy and
looking for a soundbite slip or
something they're trying to do.
Yeah,
it's weird.
And my wife is like,
what was that?
I'm like,
I,
I.
It took me an hour to sort of trying to
make you click bait.
It's not.
Well,
what's interesting too is it's sort of
an impromptu interview that you have to
do,
right?
Like if someone said,
hey,
this guy's name is Mike,
he lives in studio city,
wants you to go to his house and he's
gonna film you,
he's going to ask you a wacky questions.
He was like,
no,
but if Mike shows up at the baggage
claim and puts a camera in your face,
hey sean,
Jennifer Anniston,
man,
what's up with the Botox?
You're like,
what the fuck?
You know what I mean?
That's how they get.
Like,
you wouldn't do an interview with them
under any other circumstances,
which is one of like,
one of the weird things that happened
during the Roseanne Barr things.
Roseanne Barr when her show was canceled
and all the controversy was going on.
She was supposed to do the podcast and
it became a big news thing,
but because she put it on her,
uh,
her twitter that I'm going to do it.
And we talked about it and then they
tried to show up at the podcast studio.
So they had all these news people
standing outside the podcast studio with
their microphones were out out in front
of where Joe Rogan does his podcast and
they thought for some reason just
because they're there,
people have to talk to them.
I'm here,
talk to me.
The,
the,
they're made out of milk.
They're barely human.
The way they talk is the most boring
version of an interview you'd ever get
ever.
It's a tiny,
quick little soundbite where they feel
like,
because they're,
they're like,
the camera's on,
I've got the microphone.
Come on,
do it.
If they said,
hey,
you know,
kw,
fuck yourself once you to come in and
sit down for an interview,
you'd be like,
no,
I don't want to.
I don't want to talk to them.
I don't have anything to say.
Like I'll do all my talking on the
podcast.
But.
Well,
but,
and also if you're,
I mean I'm in the business,
but again,
I'm not somebody that does a tremendous
amount of press or at least not until a
couple weeks ago.
Um,
and if you're not accustomed to that,
it's terrifying.
It's weird because somebody puts a
camera in your face because immediately
you're thinking like,
well,
if I just go,
you know what man?
Fuck you.
Like I don't have time for that.
Yeah.
Then you're going to.
So you just think like,
I can't even walk away from this.
So you just feel like you're all of a
sudden somebody throw a cage over you.
They're not even asking you,
can I do this?
They're just doing it.
They're just,
hey shawn.
Yeah.
Let me ask you a question,
Shawn.
It's forced.
It's forced on you.
It puts you in a weird spot.
It's like all the sudden you're in your.
You're on your,
on your heels,
because your instinct is to be
defensive.
If someone could say you're.
You know what I mean?
Your instinct is not going to be.
I'll give the most thoughtful answer to
this because it's,
it's,
it's in the moment.
Someone just dropped it on you,
so now you're like,
okay,
and,
and your,
your emotions might be kind of all over
the place and you're not,
you're not stopping to like,
like having a conversation.
You're just sort of trying to figure
your way out of it and how many people
have ruined their careers or lives on
those things just said,
just fucked up and said one,
they're just trying to be funny or just
that's the thing,
because they'll miss mutated and then
they get ya,
and then they put it up and you're like,
fuck,
why did I think through that?
I was coming home from the airport.
I was tired.
I was jet lagged.
Bordain got a shitload of death threats
because he said they asked him if you
had to serve dinner to Kim Jong Un and
Donald trump,
what would you serve?
You said Hemlock,
it's trying to be funny,
and then you all these mega fucking
morons protestors were there.
They were all sending these tweets like
Potus,
you know,
he's threatening potus and it was so
strange.
Like,
where,
where is the NFL?
You know,
where's the secret service?
They should lock this motherfucker up
and like,
you guys are crazy.
It's a joke.
And that's the thing right there is that
click bait articles are they all make it
so it'll say like so and so said this
and they make it sound like somebody
like called a press conference to say
something ridiculous.
And really it was like you said,
it'll be some offhand remark and then
people out there that are judging,
they,
they never have anybody walk up and put
a camera in their face and they just
think,
well I would never say anything like
that.
It's like you don't know what you would
say.
You're never in that situation.
It's bizarre.
It's very bizarre.
Bizarre.
So how many of these things did you have
to do to promote this film?
Because it,
because of this film was based in large
part of it.
On your actual life experiences of
adopting these kids.
How many of these things did you have to
wind up doing a lot?
Because I did,
we did our press junket in New York and
I've done junkets and usually I do like
six or seven or 15 or whatever I did in
two days.
I did like 90,
95 sort of the same questions keep
coming back to over and over again.
You start developing these canned
responses.
That's the thing you have to,
and this is a mistake and this gets back
to what you were getting at before,
is that when I would do press on my
movies in the past,
I'd go to the junket and people would
come in and they didn't ask you more or
less the same questions.
And I always felt weird because I just
felt like,
no,
I just want to have a conversation with
you.
I don't want to be like
this disingenuous guy.
And then I would be sort of changing up
my answers and trying to kind of just
essentially just made it boring and I
wasn't really making any kind of a point
whatsoever.
So,
uh,
on this one they were like,
look,
you've got a message with this movie.
You've got things you want to get out
with this movie.
You've got to learn how to do this.
So I went,
I went to like a day of media training
and it was,
I did,
I did.
And it was the worst part was I've done
interviews and I've been fine before,
but I got this guy sitting across from
me who's,
who's interviewing me doing this mock
interview and then I've got the
publicist and my writing partner and
they're just staring at me and that will
listen.
I can't do it.
Right.
All the pressures there.
Who's teaching you?
Who's teaching this training?
Where they right away?
Like,
you kinda suck at this.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean they were really nice about it.
They were like,
okay,
well there's some,
there's some room for improvement.
Oh my God.
Really?
Oh yeah.
No,
it was the worst.
It will seem like a natural.
I mean there's what,
what is there to teach you?
Well now what?
Well this,
this is the thing that I'm really
comfortable with this with,
with us just hanging out here talking.
But this is what I do is I yammer when
I'm,
I'm a nervous talker.
So you asked me a question if I'm
nervous,
I just kind of go and go and go.
And people are like,
Geez us man,
that guy talk.
So the thing is,
I got this guy sent across me,
really nice guy and he's The guy who's
coaching me,
but I know I'm going to give you like
fake interviews.
Well,
he'd have a coach you first he gave me.
He gave me a lot of really good insights
and the funny thing is every rule that
he's saying as he's saying it,
I'm going,
Oh yeah,
I do that.
like everything he's saying that I
shouldn't be doing.
I'm like,
oh yeah,
that's.
I always do.
What is he saying you shouldn't be
doing?
I mean that the main thing,
it's Kinda like what we were getting at
before that when somebody is setting a
trap for you,
because so much of right now media
training is just about don't go out and
get yourself into trouble by going in
and just talking about some ridiculous
area that.
Because that's what people,
that's what everybody's trying to do
now.
Like just as a.
for example,
I did a Time magazine interview about
adoption about a year before we even
made the movie.
Really?
Yeah.
And it was just because,
uh,
I was in the process of working on the
movie and anyway,
so the whole thing was just about
adoption in my family and whatever.
And it was right when the Harvey
Weinstein stuff was blowing up.
So the lady's really nice interviewing
you.
And then at the end she says,
uh,
hey,
you know,
since I'm talking to a Hollywood
director,
I'd be remiss if I didn't ask did you
know about that Harvey Weinstein stuff?
And I was like,
Nah.
And I didn't even think about my answer
because I don't know,
I didn't know the guy was never around
any of it.
That's sort of like more like fancy
movies.
And I was like,
yeah,
know I don't,
I don't know,
I never met the guy,
whatever.
I didn't think anything of it.
I got off the phone and then I thought,
oh,
she didn't say,
what do you think about this stuff?
She said,
did you know about that stuff?
And it was like,
and yeah,
I knew,
but I kept it a secret fuck those
people.
And I just thought right away,
I,
I just,
you know,
so yeah,
it's,
it's sneaky.
That's a sneaky way of asking to sneaky
way to get you to,
you know.
Yeah.
Did you know what,
if you don't enter his kept his secret
for years.
I'm such a dumb shit.
I would have,
like you said before,
I think I think a year or two ago I
might have made a joke,
you know,
and been like,
oh yeah,
I was there,
you know,
and just printing.
Yeah.
Was there.
And then I'd be like,
what,
you know.
So uh,
so you know,
a lot of it is just just to kind of
teach you how to just sort of stay on
point so that you don't get dragged down
these weird roads into these things that
just,
that people are looking to get you in on
clickbait.
So did you bring up that instance when
you went through the training?
Oh yeah.
Did you say what should I have said?
I think I did.
I think and,
and really what they,
what they teach you.
It was funny because believe it or not,
he said,
I'm going to show you some clips of,
you know,
sort of doing it right and doing it
wrong.
Oh,
they have disaster clips.
They say they do and one of them the
file that you sent to Jim before the
show,
but you guys will probably all know this
one,
they showed me a clip of Quentin
Tarantino,
sort of like getting really angry with
this reporter.
Was that the violent thing?
I thought it was kind of to kick some
guys asked that lady was like,
your films are disgusting and violent.
And he was like,
yeah,
they're fucking movies dummy.
Like he gets really upset about it.
And where was this?
Actually I ref it's the same one because
the one that I saw was a guy.
Oh,
I saw him with a lady.
Uh,
but that was via sat,
like,
so this is a different one.
Then there was one where the guy was
threatening to kick the guy's ass.
I don't.
The one that I saw didn't go that far,
but what?
I actually kinda liked what he said
because he was like,
no,
I'm not playing that game with you.
I'm not doing any.
Got Off.
But I was sort of like,
Eh,
you know,
I liked that he does that.
I mean I,
I liked the one with the lady.
The lady is like,
your movies are so violent and awful,
and he was like a movie a make believe
thing.
It's not real violence.
Like he really sas or it's funny as
shit.
And then I also,
she,
where was she?
She was doing,
you know,
she was,
she was like,
good morning Pittsburgh,
like the entertainment reporter and then
he was actually probably doing like
satellite stuff everywhere and he was
just like,
you're dumb.
But I also saw there's that guy,
he's a Gotcha guy too.
Did a Robert Downey Jr.
It was promoting a movie too.
I don't know if they showed you that
one.
Oh,
that one.
Right.
And the guy said,
now your drug addiction.
He was like,
wait,
what?
It was totally to try to get him to in a
moment,
robert downey jr is not having it.
He's like,
I'm here to promote a movie.
Yeah.
Um,
this has nothing to do with that.
Totally.
But let's,
let's get into your drug addiction
during your darkest times.
Like,
what are you talking about?
Man?
Iron mans out.
I'm not doing my hair for that.
Well,
it's just like the ends it too.
They're so selfish.
Like that thing is so doing shit like
that is so selfish.
It's such a sneaky little thing to do.
Yeah.
What did they teach you though?
Like in that moment of like when they're
just like,
don't,
don't get emotional.
It's like don't take the bait and,
and more than anything for me,
because I look,
I'm from Wisconsin and I still have that
kind of.
everybody's nice.
Everybody has good intentions to five,
you know,
so,
and I had this experience on my very
first movie where I,
I talked to this reporter because it was
a movie about a,
it was a road trip,
you know,
this,
this silly road trip comedy,
you know,
and I talked to this reporter and he
says,
and he was just being,
he was being really cool.
We were just kInda hanging out after
this thing talking and he's like sit and
gas prices were really high and he goes,
so,
uh,
he's like,
you feel weird about making a road trip
movie when gas prices are so high.
And I,
and I said,
eh,
I don't know,
I,
you know,
maybe if the movie tanks I can just
blame it on that no one could afford to
go to the theater because the prices
were so high and I don't think.
And then this article comes out that
just the guy literally said I was
swarthy looking and it just,
he just painted me like an absolute
piece of shit and I was like,
that guy was so cool.
Like he was like when we were talking
and then he just destroyed me.
I've been there.
Yeah,
I'm sure you guys have.
it's all new to me.
I remember one too that like,
who did it to me,
like when I was just doing phone,
like a phone interview for press before
I was selling any tickets and the guy
was just like a really nice guy and
totally twisted things.
And made it seem like,
just like he knOws what I was saying and
he purposely twisted things around and
then it had no impact,
but I remember reading that and being
like,
oh fuck this guy.
And,
and be careful when you talk to these
people because he totally,
he knows what I was trying to say and I
read this article.
It's like he misRepresented everything.
Yeah.
Well that's the only way they can have
fun.
And that's the only.
I mean if you're just a normal guy and
you give a,
you know,
normal answers and you're thoughtful and
considerate,
that's not as good for them.
Right.
It's so twisted around,
well it's not just,
it's not as profitable.
It's more profitable.
And especially if it's an online thing
with an online thing,
you need to click bait title.
You need a bunch of people clicking on
that thing because otherwise you're not
going to get any ad revenue for it.
Yes.
It's a very bizarre model where it's
encouraging people to be deceptive and
to make these things inflammatory.
And I got to say,
look,
I did,
like I said,
I did 90,
95 interviews and in the course of two
days and virtually everybody was really
cool,
really asking really thoughtful,
interesting question.
So I don't want to make it sound like
I'm ripping on tHe whole press over
this.
But yeah,
there are these people.
And that's the thing is that if it was
every single person that came along,
it would almost be easier because you
could just kind of be like,
okay,
here we go.
I got it.
But you,
but you get like 30,
really good,
you know,
reporters with integrity and good
people.
And then somebody jumps in and you're
like,
oh,
and then then,
then they catch you not looking because
you're not looking for that guy there.
Also get super
jaded.
You know,
it's almost like cops that have arrested
too many people.
Everyone's a crook.
Like they just think that everybody that
we're interviewing is a piece of shit.
And it's also like they're interviewing
these hollywood people.
They're thinking of you,
you had a big mansion and driving a
mercedes.
You've got all this money.
Fuck this guy,
it's like this instant take on it.
Oh,
a hollywood director.
Yeah.
Right.
How's your casting couch?
Yeah.
ShIt.
Yeah,
that's true.
It's true.
And it becomes the game.
I think too,
for them the game is like,
let's see if I can get one and we should
be really clear.
This is not.
Most people,
most people are nice,
but it's just like one.
Even if it's only one out of 10,
you run into that one.
you're like,
fuck these things.
I don't want to do those things anymore.
totally terrifying because you think
about your family,
your friends,
like anybody who's going to cause now
there,
there is this.
I know you guys talked about this a lot.
There is this culture out there where
people are completely reduced to like
one moment or one statement or whatever
it is and that's all you are.
Is that whatever that thing that
happened in that one moment and you
know,
you see it happening to people all the
time and you think about so.
So when you'Re there and you feel like
you're just a regular guy,
you don't feel like you know that it's
really scary because you think about
your kids and you think of it,
you know,
so it's a,
it's a scary situation.
Yeah.
Well,
it's a weirD time for these publications
to be taken in consideration.
No one's really buying magazines and
newspapers like they used to.
It's hard to sell and so they're reduced
to these online publications and they
have to compete with a bunch of these
click baity bullshit things and that's
where the money is.
I mean,
even in New York times,
man,
the New York times is resulting to a lot
of click baity shit now.
And you're like,
wow,
well do you guys have that feeling?
Like when you're online that you're on
liquor clickbait diet where you see
things where you're like,
oh man,
I totally want to eat that right now,
but I'm not.
I'm not gonna do that ingredient in a
box.
So sweet to navigate it.
Now you read that title and you're like,
I know this will have no substance.
just the headline,
I'm fascinated to see where this goes
because this didn't exist,
right?
These online click baity things didn't
exist 20 years ago and now they're
everywhere.
it's like what?
What's gonna happen in 10 years?
Like,
where's it going to be like,
where's this going?
Yeah.
I'm very fascinated,
you know,
very,
very fascinated to see.
It feels like a transitional time.
It doesn't feel like it can Hold out
like this forever.
That's true.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I agree.
Because it hurts.
I mean,
and this is,
this is the reason why I think podcasts,
culture is coming on strong because it's
a place where people just talk and have
a conversation and I think that fear of
slipping up and people always out there
trying to get you to slip up or
whatever,
has people not havIng as much of a free
exchange of ideas,
but through these podcasts,
one thing that does happen is people
will take a very small clip out of
context and then write a whole article
about that small clip with a big click
baity headline like thompson sigora
shits all over people in Somalia and
then you know,
whatever it is,
and then do that.
No,
I mean it was a different city.
I just made something up.
But then you know,
it could be completely out of context
and over a giant overall discussion of a
top of a topic that took place over 45
minutes and they'll take 30 seconds of
that and put a youtube clip up and then
you get a bunch of angry people at you.
That's true.
But the other flip side of it is that I
feel like in this time we're developing
more of an audience that is quick to
call that shit out.
So while there are going to be people
that take the bait and be like,
what is it?
Get angry.
There's a bunch of people who are like
really quick to recognize that that's
taken out of context.
Well,
it's because people like you and I and a
lot of other people that do podcasts
talk about that all the time.
So people hear it all the time,
they see the examples of it and you go,
wow,
that's crazy.
Some of it is so egregious.
You're like,
yeah,
you're a piece of shit.
Like someone should pull your license.
Like if you were a doctor,
they'd fully pull your fucking license
as a journalist.
He was a lot of wiggle room with p and a
piece of shit.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But these are journalists,
air quotes,
these podcasts.
This,
this medium is just going to grow and
people are embracing more this long form
conversation and understanding things by
talking about it for awhile.
Well,
and the other part of it that I think
that gets lost sometimes is that,
You know,
like right now we're talking about like
journalists,
but the great journalists are just as
hurt by this.
This stUff is everyone because the
people that are really out there being
thoughtful,
really researching their material,
really talking to people,
getting to the bottom of things.
That whole journalistic work ethic that
we all grew up hearing about.
The,
those people are just as threatened by
this cheap,
the sort of attack journalism that
happens because they can't even compete
with it,
with a,
with a really thoughtful,
well researched story.
And then somebody like he touched a boob
and then there's like the,
they get all the clicks.
You know,
I was talking to matt taibbi who's a
real journalist and matt taibbi was
discussing the pieces that he wrote on
wall street and uh,
the,
uh,
the crash of 2008 and all the fucking
shenanigans that went on with that and
how much just crazy shit they're allowed
to do and what they can,
what a ponzi scheme.
A loT of that 2008 crash was.
And you went,
I was talking to him,
I realized he had put a year into
research learning like he did not come
from a background in finance,
so he put a year into researching all
the aspects of the savings and loan
crisis,
all the aspects of the mortgage crisis
and how it took place and how they were,
how they were making money off of this
and how they were betting on things
falling apart and moving money around
and how fucking chaotic it is and how
crazy it is.
And then you think of how much time put
on that and then in proportion how few
people actually read that and how little
it affected the actual economy itself.
Like how little things changed and how
little people were outraged.
Like his article,
I don't know if you ever read the
rolling stone piece on it.
Fucking amazing,
But you don't work on that for forever.
Yeah,
but you don't care that much about it.
You know what I mean?
It's like those people never went to
jail.
The billions of dollars just just
disappeared.
It all got moved around and everybody,
abracadabra and they moved the cape data
and then it moves on and you know,
and he details it in this amazing way
and you realize like,
wow,
how many of those guys are left?
How many of those real journalists or
are left?
Right.
And this is a,
I mean it,
you have to invest in something like
that.
I mean,
he's putting a year into just
researching what this is all about.
Yeah,
it's fucking insane.
I mean,
and then instead,
you know,
it's like a kim kardashian got her butt
done again,
boom,
boom.
50 times more.
People are paying attention to that,
that.
Well,
let me ask you this because I think in a
weird way,
this weird time that we're in right now
could actually be the rebirth of that
kind of journalism that you're talking
about because I know that that when,
when everything was getting kind of
crazy and people were,
you know,
were talking about all this.
I did a subscribe to some,
you know,
like the online version of some papers
because I thought,
oh,
I do want to support people that are
actually,
you know,
people with integrity that are out there
chasing stories,
do the,
informing the world,
you know,
and helping us out.
Also they fuck you over if you don't do
it,
you can't read like 10 New York times
article and they cut you off.
Like,
oh,
you know,
you have to subscribe.
Yeah.
Good for you though.
You know what I mean?
It kind of have to.
I wish it was a little easier to do
though is set it up with apple one click
or some shit,
you know,
I think it is now.
Yeah.
It's kind of a pain.
I don't get that.
Why I subscribe to a few of them and if
I go to the app,
obviously everything's fine,
but if I try to read it through another
link,
it's like,
ah,
you already subscribed.
Know it's kind of annoying because then
you got to jump into the app and then
find the story again.
And it's annoying.
But I get it.
I mean they have to figure out some way
to generate a revenue and this whole,
these last two years have been huge for
the subscriptions on those.
I mean Like grown by millions,
you know,
as,
as print paper has gone down,
those online subscriptions have gone
way,
way up.
really?
oh yeah,
yeah.
That's what they're profitable.
Definitely.
I mean I just saw that whoever the
editor in chief of a New York times
doing an art,
an interview about their recent
subscription model,
it was impressive.
I mean really went high.
Well if you do good work,
and I mean there's people out there that
have a hunger for asheville,
real journalism and also in depth
intelligent,
comprehensive understandings of what is
happening.
Like the real,
real,
a well researched take on a particular
situation when somebody does it like
that guy did about like the subprime
mortgage,
you know,
and they spent all that time and they
write that story.
I mean it's like reading a good book.
I just can't stop reading.
I mean,
did you read that dirty john story in
the la times?
What does that Man,
and now they're making a,
they have like a mini series coming out
about it.
I remember reading it and not being able
to stop reading it and it was like an
eight part series in the la times about
this guy who was a sociopath who would
go on dating sites and basically bait
women who were like divorcees,
who had some money.
He was posturing as a doctor and he
would pretend to have this really
successful life and just be a pariah
that would like suck onto these people.
And this story went really deep about
how this guy found this woman.
Her daughters were like grown daughters
immediately suspected things were wrong.
She didn't see it,
but the story unravels the way,
like a good book or like a thriller
would,
you know,
would unravel and in the theater.
So you're just like,
like the guy,
you know,
he researched it,
I forget his name,
they turned it into a podcast and then
now it's coming out as a,
like a short series.
That's the guy.
That's the guy,
that's the real guy.
Wow.
Christopher gafford and men.
So it would be like part one in the
series,
you'd read this and you're like,
all right,
worst part.
Like you're like scrambling to read the
next.
That's freaking me out because he's
moving images,
moving slowly,
slowly pulling away.
Real guy.
It's a fascinating read and I recommend
reading it,
man.
I mean it is really good.
So was this guy a career criminal
criminal?
He was a career crIminal that hit it
well,
but um,
you know,
it's interesting.
I remember reading it and you're kind of
fascinated how the daughters know,
like they just know they keep going back
to like,
this doesn't add up,
but she's kind of lost in the love and
attention and exciteMent and this
relationship and he's just praying on
it.
He Is preying on her.
He empties her account.
I didn't want to give it away,
man.
It's so good.
Yeah,
you can get it right now.
You just.
Do you have a subscription or did you
like it's a podcast,
a bunch of articles about how big it got
released and podcasts and la times.
There's all sorts of stories about it.
Well,
there's still,
I mean for all the people that are into
just short attention span,
clickbait nonsense,
there's still
and there's some sort of a market for,
for real,
it's actually real real stories and real
partners and I would say that that's
what most of it is out there.
It's just that we get the so much of.
I mean there's such a stock pile of that
stuff every day,
but when it comes to the actual stories
that you're reading,
I don't know,
maybe I'm pollyanna about it,
but I feel like there's.
There's a lot of great stuff out there.
I think there's,
there's plenty of great stuff.
Can you think about the actual amount of
content versus hoW much time you
actually have to read?
There is great stuff,
but if you looked at the overwhelming
appetite that people have for media,
it's for nonsense.
Like I was watching the wendy williams
show.
I've never watched that show before.
She's christ.
I of watching that show.
First of all,
there was a girl in the audience that
had a crown on.
It was hilarious.
The audience alone,
like he should have won.
We should married herself.
She wasn't done.
Tom and I were at a restaurant last
night and the lady had just gotten
married to herself.
it was when we were both.
We found out what's going on over there,
and then someone was like,
she's marrying yourself.
this is your ceremony.
Never seen guys doing that much in my.
My oldest daughter went over and hugged
her and grabbed my oldest daughter is
the sweetest person in the world.
Yeah.
She was like,
she's so sweeT that the lady who married
herself was like,
your daughter is very sweet.
She wanted to marry her.
She was like,
listen,
I'm married to myself,
but I'm you too.
Let's marry everybody.
Yeah.
Um,
but,
uh,
what were we just talking about?
Um,
what the wendy williams show.
Oh my goodness.
Was that when she fell down?
Yeah,
she had,
she had a moment on the show.
Have you seen them?
Have you seen the.
What I saw when aretha died,
that aretha had done an interview with
wendy williams one time and it was
fucking hilarious because aretha
franklin was sassing her a bunch of
like,
oh gee,
sassing.
It was reaLly,
really funny,
man,
I don't know if you've seen it,
but she's just like,
like a wendy's,
like I have an idea for this project,
whatever it was,
and she was like,
so you want to go in on it and a wreath
is like,
you're going to write a check?
And she's like,
I was thinking you coach.
She was like,
oh,
you ain't got it.
Huh?
You ain't got the money.
That's what I thought.
She just turns around on her.
it's so funny.
Hilarious.
Read the franklin just so just owns it,
you know,
she's been around.
She was like not having it at all.
Well,
all the show is wendy williams talking
shit about people and all the girls in
the audience and they're talking about
people getting custody and all she
breaking up with her and it's like,
wow,
that's what scares a lot of people out
there that have an appetite for that.
Uh,
for sure.
I mean,
how long does me,
obviously I sat there watching it,
like who will look to help jerry
springer state on the right look?
Yeah.
That was a fucking 30 plus year run or
something.
You know what's fucked up about that?
Jerry sprInger is a smart guy.
Yeah.
He's a smart guy.
I used to listen to them on the opiod
anthony show.
I was like,
whoa,
wait a minute.
He was the mayor of cincinnati.
Mayerson said he got busted paying for a
prostitute with a check.
So we all slip up from time to time.
That's how he got caught.
Yeah.
We just hilarious.
Like checking into county on that.
Right.
You wanted a lexus who's lexus?
Yeah.
It's pretty crazy,
man.
It's a.
I dunno.
It's.
I think there's plenty.
What does that.
Does that him?
Wow.
That's when he was the mayor.
A young fellow.
He's like 40 years old back then,
but it's just bizarre how prevalent that
stuff is online.
I mean it's just,
there's so much.
There's so much click baity nonsense.
It's hard,
but there's,
there's plenty of good journalism is
plenty good writing.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
again,
like I said,
when when I was doing the,
my,
my limited experience in doing this,
the vast,
vast,
vast majority of the people that I've
been talking to have been really
interested in just talking about
adoption and really interested in foster
care and all that kind of stuff and it's
been great.
It's been great talking,
talking to everYbody and I think that
when you have a topic like that too,
it helps because they're not really
trying to crush you as much when you're
know when you're talking to them about
kids who need families and homes and
that kind of thing.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah,
yeah.
They have to be careful With letting
their piece of shit claws out.
Now you said that your experience with
adopting three kids started out as a
nightmare.
yeah.
How did it start out as it goes into it?
You know,
do you have friends that joined the
military and where they,
they're in high school,
they think they're really tough and they
were like,
yeah,
it's going to be awesome.
And then they go to bootcamp and then
they're like,
oh shit,
this is really hard.
And then they get on top of it and then
they're good again,
you know.
But they have to go through that
transition of like,
oh man,
maybe I'm not as tough as I thought I
was.
And then they get tough.
So you'd never had any kids.
I never had any kids dog eat dog thing
there.
The dog thing.
You to take care of a very small way.
I had a friend who said that to me.
So I'm like,
well I've had a dog.
Oh yeah.
Talking about having a kid.
I'm gonna fucking kill you with a rock.
Not compare the two.
Yeah.
And we know we,
we went from,
you know,
zero kids and you kind of think,
well I babysat my sister's kids and that
kind of.
How long that.
Yeah,
that's,
that's the movie I went to a whole
movie.
Yeah.
And even what happens is you go.
So,
so for us we had a really interesting
experience where we went to an adoption
fair and that's,
that's in the movie.
It's a real thing where they,
because they,
you know,
their budgets are stretched so tight
that they'll have these outdoor events,
not every county has them,
but la county has them where you,
uh,
where they'll bring a bunch of kids that
are,
that are in the system and a bunch of a
prospective parents and they'll just
have like games and stuff going on.
It's a really bizarre event.
And we went,
you know,
and you're there to meet kids,
to meet your kids.
And uh,
so we went there and we didn't want to
have anything to do with teenagers
because that,
you know,
just because we were scared we thought
were,
were not ready for that.
We just want to find like some little
cute little kid,
then we can,
you know,
help out.
And uh,
and then the teenagers are all off to
the side because everybody is afraid of
him and it's the most heartbreaking
thing you've ever seen because they know
why they're there.
Like they chose to be there and they
know that everybody's scared of him.
So I was there and I was like,
oh my god,
this is the worst thing I've ever seen.
And we ended up sort of inadvertently
meeting this teenage girl and her
brother and sister and just,
they just seemed cool and they just
seemed like really good kids and just
scared,
scared.
But we wrote them down on our sheet and
just again,
not what we,
what we had planned on when we did this,
but we wrote them down on our sheet and
we went home knowing they were going to
match us with them because no one else
was going to put them down.
And we get home and we find out,
yes,
you've been matched with these kids.
And we're like,
okay,
here we go.
We're going to have,
you know,
we're going to have a temperature a,
they were 16,
13 and 11.
Yeah.
So,
so we're,
we're kind of wrapping our heads around
this over the next couple of weeks.
And we got to a place where we were
like,
okay,
you know,
we can do this.
And then we got a call from the social
worker and she said,
you know,
um,
it's not going to work out with them.
The,
uh,
they've been in the system for four
years.
The girl,
she's really holding out hope that her
mom is coming for.
So she's refusing replacement.
And so we tried to.
And I was like,
I was,
you know,
when you hear that,
it's so,
just the same reaction you guys just
had.
So my wife and I wrote a letter to send
through the,
the social workers just saying,
hey look,
we get it if you maybe you guys just
want to come and just do the foster
thing or you know however you want to do
it.
And we,
we,
we just sort of sent the letter off.
We didn't hear anything.
And then she came back and she just
said,
yeah,
it's not gonna happen.
And then she very matter of fact just
said,
but there's these other three kids.
And that was kids are my kids now who I
love more than anything in the world.
And that's,
that's how just,
there's these other three kids are like,
oh,
all right,
and you,
you want there to be,
or I shouldn't say you.
I mean,
I wanted there to be a certain amount of
randomness,
like when you have biological kids,
you don't know what you're going to get
and go into that,
that event where you're sort of like
meeting kids and if it feels weird.
And so when she said there's these other
three kids,
we said,
okay.
And then they turned out to be younger,
you know,
63 and 18 months.
Um,
but I never forgot meeting that,
that girl and her brother and sister.
So when the,
when the time came that we were going to
make a movie about it,
I really,
that was the genesis of the lizzie
character.
I wanted to make sure there was a
teenager in this movie because they're
so misunderstood.
And in the process I went out and met
with a bunch of families that had
adopted teen girls and then met with a
lot of those girls who,
some of whom are grown up.
And some of them are still,
you know,
uh,
with their families and,
and this is the thing,
you know,
the scariness that we're all talking
about,
everyone of these families that I met
with just great stories,
like amazing,
great stories,
like hard times,
you know,
try it,
trying to make that connection and
whatever.
But,
but everybody with the same story
wouldn't have it any other way.
Change our life for the better.
Met these incredible kids.
And uh,
this is.
Yeah.
And now I'm yammering,
but.
Oh,
how old are they now?
How many years have you had them?
Uh,
aLmost seven years.
So my son john,
he just turned 13.
My daughter's nine and my,
my other son is eight.
And um,
how,
how long was it between the phone call?
Like I had these other three kids.
And you actually getting them in your
house?
Um,
god,
what was it?
It was,
it was a couple of weeks because there
was weeks.
That's it.
Yeah.
No,
it wasn't long at all.
But,
uh,
yeah,
it was [inaudible] they called and they
said we have these other three kids.
And then,
uh,
and then there was going to be a meeting
because they,
they,
they won't tell you much about the kids
until,
until they really sit down with you and
then they kind of walk through like,
here's,
you know,
whatever trauma,
here's whatever,
you know,
kind of.
And again,
they don't fit in our case,
they don't have all the information
obviously on their past and they can
kind of tell you like,
here's how they came into the and that
kind of thing.
So I wasn't able to go because I was,
I was,
I was at a work thing.
And so my wife went to the meeting and I
was like listening to it,
you know,
and that was on speakerphone in the
meeting.
And uh,
and there was this one moment,
you know,
and she's telling us everything and
there's this one moment where she slides
the picture across to my wife says,
here's a picture of them and there's
this long pause.
And my wife goes,
oh,
they're cute.
But they didn't sound cute by the
inflection in their voice.
And you know,
you're trying,
you're trying not to be that guy,
you know,
what do they look like,
you don't want to be shallow about it.
I'm sure kids are kids and you know,
you're going to fall in love with them
regardless.
But you know,
like you kinda everybody wants to think
their own kids are cute,
whatever.
So it was funny.
Then when I saw the picture,
the picture was,
it was just a weird bad picture of the
kids.
like my son who was six at the time,
it looked like he was 11 and he looked
like this.
It was just the look on his face and
whatever.
Yeah.
He looked hard at all and,
and we go over to the house and these
kids are adorable.
So.
Oh,
so this is.
Sorry I'm getting ahead of myself.
So,
so when you.
So we have the meeting and we go,
okay,
we're going to go meet with them.
And just to be clear,
we didn't say okay because of the
picture,
because the picture was kind of like
neither here nor there,
you know,
we were just like,
all right,
let's go meet these kids.
So we go to the house and these kids are
adorable and,
and it's the weirdest thing ever because
you go to this foster home where they
live and you play with them for like two
hours.
And when do you ever play with any kids
for two straight hours?
like actually actively play with kids,
especially kids you've never met before.
So It's exhausting and it's weird.
And we touch on this in the movie that I
was really scared when we were getting
there because I wanted so much to walk
in.
See these kids well up with tears.
No,
it's for real.
no,
these are my kids.
And just have that like cosmic
connection moment.
And that didn't happen at all.
Like it's more weird.
Right.
So were you,
I'm going to live with you.
Yeah.
And well the,
the little kids are just kinda like
this,
you know,
it's actually weird in the other
direction.
They're so used to kind of being passed
around that they're just kinda like,
oh,
okay,
who are these people,
you know,
and so we get in there and then the,
the foster mom in our case was like a go
to your mom and dad,
and I was like,
oh,
don't do this,
don't do that because it just felt so
obtrusive to the kids,
you know?
And so we would go there every day for
five straight days.
We would go there when the kids were off
school and we'd,
we'd go and play with them first in the
backyard and then you take them to the
park and then you take him to the park
and he'd take them out for ice cream and
you're just kinda like getting to know
these kids that are strangers to try to
change their names.
Uh,
yeah.
first day,
as soon as we walked in and I was like,
no,
we didn't do that.
But a little one wouldn't even know
though,
dude.
Yeah,
that's true.
That is true.
No memory.
A lot of people do.
In fact,
a lot of kids,
a lot of older kids that sort of have
that we'll want to change their name,
not just a new fresh start.
Yeah.
That they'll just want to.
I don't have any experience with that,
but I've heard that,
that sometimes kids will choose to.
Uh,
there was uh,
a young lady that was at the screenIng
last night who was,
who her picture is at the end of the
movie and she's like,
she's In Ireland getting her phd right
now,
this girl that was adopted out of foster
care and she's,
she's amazing.
And,
and she,
she had chosen to change her name.
Yeah.
I mean,
that seems like it would mean something
now that I think about it,
it just seems,
you know,
changing a name.
Yeah.
Especially as a teen,
but I mean,
I get it if you're saying like,
I want to put everything in the past.
Yeah.
You want a fresh start.
Really lock it down.
This is the new me.
My name's brian.
I used to be number eight.
I'm tWenty four now.
Well,
and that touches on something that is
really difficult when you're doing this
as an adoptive parent,
is that you're trying to walk this line
all the time where you know you,
you need to claIm these kids for your
own.
You need to be the person who's like,
you're with us like we're,
we're,
we're with you.
We got your back.
We're behind you like you,
you,
you need to do that.
That's what these kids don't have.
this thing that we all take for granted.
We have these parents that love us no
matter what knucklehead things we do,
so you're trying to do that,
but at the same time you're trying not
to impose your world on them because
they're coming into it with their own
personality and their own culture or
whatever it is that behind them.
So you're always trying to kind of be
careful and walk this line between just
just completely
bring them in,
but not trying to change them into who
you are.
Did thE six year old already have things
he was really into or sports or
activities or.
Yeah,
he was.
Well,
the funny thing is my son is really
athletic and I'm,
I'm really not so I know you guys are,
but I'm,
I'm so nomis and me especially,
he's an acrobat.
You saw what I was doing yesterday
because an animal,
but uh,
but no,
he's really athletic and he's just
always been good with,
with all of that stuff and it's funny
for me because I wasn't that kid at all,
but it's great for me because I'm like,
he's able to do the stuff that I wanted
so badly when I was little.
I suckEd at sports and I so wanted to be
good at sports and he's really good at
it and it makes me.
What does he play?
Well,
he,
whatever he plays,
he's just tends to be pretty good at it.
So he played flag football for awhile
and he's playing lacrosse now and he's
played soccer or lacrosse and football.
We're just planning it with brendan
schaub the other day.
I had no idea how many people get
knocked the fuck out.
Playing lacrosse.
Lacrosse is.
Oh my god.
Island man.
Violent.
We were saying like there's a difference
between this,
even in football,
in that they're striking,
each are allowed to.
You're allowed to hit each other with
the stick,
but they're also striking each other
with elbows to running in and they have
the stick in their hand and they're
elbowing each other in the face as the
running.
I mean,
oh shit.
It's a crazy amount of force that they
generate.
Oh yeah.
And these kids are getting flatlined
because I had dale earnhardt jr here
that day on really nice guy.
Great guy.
Suffered 12 concussions over a period of
four years racing.
Yes.
And has some significant brain damage
because of it that he had to go through
therapy for to,
to help them like to the point where he
was walking and he had to hold onto
things because his balance was so fucked
up.
He couldn't,
couldn't just walk,
couldn't get off the couch and walk to
the bathroom.
He had to hold onto like a table and a
chair and hit him.
Make his way through all of this from
concussions.
And you know what they're getting in
lacrosse.
So they're getting in football,
it's all the same shit.
Head trauma,
head trauma.
Yeah.
So I'm a terrible parent.
My kids go to a very nice school.
It's a great school and we went to a
football game the other day where the
older kids are playing football and I'm
just sitting there.
All the other parents are having a good
time and I'm like,
brain damage,
braIn damage.
There's some brain damage.
there's some brain.
I'm like,
jesus fucking christ.
These are kids.
They're kids running at each of the full
clip,
smashing it with Jordan falling to the
ground and see the kid get up slow and
hope put his hands on the ground.
He's all fucked up.
I'm like,
this is crazy.
Like I felt like people.
I always felt like lacrosse because my,
my high school had lacrosse too and I
always felt like it was way crazier ones
because I didn't know about it.
And then I'm at the school and they have
it.
I'm like,
this shit is.
Because they have stiffness.
Yeah.
And they're just,
oh yeah,
of course.
Yes.
If you're a football player,
you can become some herschel walker type
character and become a baller.
Yeah,
that's true.
But you got no shot if you're a lacrosse
player.
I love when they interview like all the
guys,
the nfl,
they're like,
uh,
the young guys to like,
you know,
all this evidence is that your lifespan
is going to be way shorter and it's
gonna be probably horrific at some point
because of the impact of what you're
going through playing football,
you know,
what did you think about that?
The like,
shit's worth it,
man.
This is awesome lifestyle.
Nobody is like,
you're getting some guys that you see
retire early,
which was unheard of 10 years ago.
Guys.
One guy came out,
played his rookie year and retired,
you know,
you're getting guys early retirement.
Um,
some guys play,
finish out a contractor up for a big
contract and they're out.
Yeah,
that's happening.
But there's still,
you know,
there's no shortage of guys were like,
I'll take the guarantee whatever my
signing bonuses and take some brain
damage it.
That's how our brains work.
Our brains are designed to not have that
kind of foresight and you get much
older.
Of course,
young satisfy me now and I don't know
what that is,
but you can tell people,
hey,
whatever it is you're doing right now,
this is really good at causing
irreparable harm when like today.
No.
Well fuck it.
You know?
Well,
that's the same way we deal with climate
change.
Yeah.
Literally the same thing.
People were driving around with cars
blowing smoke.
I like,
yeah,
one day of every fucking fix it.
There's going to be a real problem.
You tell someone to be a real problem
here on earth and like 300 years and
they're like,
that sucks.
Whatever,
whatever.
I won't be here bro.
Or even 40 years,
sadly.
Yeah.
It will be like,
there's also the issue is people that
get a lot of head trauma that they get
very impulsive and they,
um,
they don't make good decisions anyway.
So even if you know,
even if they could have the foresight,
they probably would make good decisions.
They're don't,
they're not thinking rationally.
And they did some study.
What was that study jamie?
We've referenced this before where they,
um,
they looked at kIds that play football
literally from pop warner all the way
through college and how many of them
have ct?
He really,
oh,
jesus chrIst.
It's stunning.
See,
I always felt like my,
my point of view on it was always like,
I played football fourth grade through
high school,
right.
And I always just like men.
That's why you're so fucked up.
I know,
but I just feel like,
you know,
the,
like you have definitely some big in a,
in an amateur career,
you have some,
you can think back.
Like,
man,
I got my bell rung a bell rung.
I don't know.
I mean probably,
I mean here's the thing,
in fourth grade and fifth grade you're
like,
that doesn't happen really.
I mean kids were like,
you know,
walking up and wrapping up slowly.
You,
you're playing with kids who will
eventually not play football even in
sixth grade.
So it starts to be,
you might have like a stud on a team in
middle school and still a bunch of guys
that won't play in high school and in
high school.
Yeah,
there's definitely some uh,
athletes that stand out for sure.
I mean those are the kids that will
eventually go on,
but you play teams are and there's weeks
where you're just like,
no one is
really good on this team,
you know,
and you'll have a game where you'll feel
like,
yeah,
I mean there was a couple of,
I've got a couple good hits and there
was nothing really have impact and then
something will stand out.
Like you'll play a school that has like
an allstate or all american player.
You're like,
holy shit,
that guy fucking fucked me up bad.
And,
and you remember it.
I mean I remember it to this day,
some of those like really standout guys
and you're like,
that hit stuck with me,
but that's once a year that you play
that guy,
right?
Or that you remember a school that good
and then if you don't go on to play in
college really feels like kind of a,
I don't know,
a risk assessment where you're like,
I didn't feel like that was,
you know,
do I have damage?
I don't know.
But I mean,
once you get into college,
football is where I feel like that's
where you're really playing with really
good athletes.
A friend of mine,
a guy in his neighborhood,
I'm a kid who was 21 committed suicide
and he was a college player who was
about to go into,
into the pros.
He was 21 years old really.
And um,
the uh,
significant cte,
like just really ravaged.
He,
every year a player played tackle
football under the age,
predicted the early onset of cognitive
problems by two point four years in
behavioral and mood problems by two
point five years.
Yeah.
But there's a study.
This is okay.
Our study found that 211 players who
diagnosed with cte after death,
who played tackle football before age
12,
suffered from cognitive behavioral and
mood symptoms earlier than those players
didn't start to play till after age 12.
They're saying that,
okay,
study included 246 former players,
211 of whom were diagnosed with cte
after death.
That's insane.
Blinn college,
there's,
there's definitely,
there's no such thing as getting around
real high impact hits.
That's it.
Those are all people that know how to
play.
They're all athletes getting rock.
What they're realizing now is that
subconcussive trauma is what's
responsible for the majority of brain
damage.
What's subconcussive?
You're not getting a concussion.
Oh yeah.
You just get rattled.
Getting rattled where it's not even
fucking you up,
but over time,
over time,
that over and multiple hits that are
just not.
They're not knocking you out that just
jostling you.
You can always happen a lot.
Yeah.
Even get it from getting hit to the
body.
Right?
When you get hit to the body and your
head snaps back and you don't even get
hit in the head and you're like throwing
up and your head's all fucked up and you
try and figure out what's going on.
It's because your brain's been moshing
around inside of your head.
Yeah.
The thing that I remember too,
the thing that stands out is when you.
Because it's such thing as like bracing
for a hit and then feeling it and you're
like,
fuck,
but when you don't see someone coming.
Oh yeah,
that's like a fight.
You know?
You don't see a punch comIng.
Oh yeah,
100 percent.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's,
it's dangerous.
You guys are saving my child's life,
right?
I'm telling you right now.
He's good.
It's funny because I,
I don't know that much about lacrosse.
I had to actually like youtube lacrosse
to be like,
how did you some of the video?
Because there's some videos of some
fucking hits that we were watching the
other day and brendan played lacrosse in
college.
He played lacrosse in college and
football jesus,
and then he fought in the ufc,
so his brain looks like a walnut.
It's got to be man.
You talked to him.
You kind of know it's a,
it's a crazy fucking sports.
People would watch these guys just over
and over again.
These guys getting code,
boom,
boom.
See that?
I mean they're smashing each other.
The impact is horrific.
Oh look at that.
Boom.
This.
These are strikes.
This is like me kicking somebody in the
head.
This is,
this is not much different than a kick
in the head.
You just bring them with an elbow,
but the amount of force.
so these guys getting kicked in the head
with these helmets on and if you think
the helmet is protecting your head,
that shit ain't protecting anything.
Boom.
Look at that.
All right,
look,
I don't know anything about this stuff,
but I've thought for a long time.
Hard helmets.
Got to just make it worse,
right?
Well,
it makes you more confident that you got
slammed your head into somebody and then
you don't realize how bad you're getting
fucked up from that.
You know it's your head when you get hit
in the head,
even though you have a helmet on it,
it's not going to crack your skull,
your brain cells still subset.
It's hitting you.
You get serious punishment.
Smashing around in there.
You're all the connective tissue.
It's like,
oh,
it's awful.
It's awful.
Boom.
And this is coming from a guy who's
probably seen.
I probably see more people get fucked up
than 99 point nine percent of the people
that have ever lived in terms of like
being there live.
When someone got the fuck beat out of
them,
I probably see more people get the fuck
beat out of him than almost anyone
that's ever lived in history.
It's probably a small handful of people
that have seen more.
Sure.
So yeah.
How many fights have you called?
Hundreds.
Thousands.
At least more than a thousand.
Probably 2,000.
But then I've seen more.
I've seen a bunch of live in.
when I was competing I saw a bunch of
people get fucked up.
I mean it's just,
I've seen it a lot.
It's that when you can avoid that,
avoid it,
you know,
especially something like lacrosse,
you can't,
can't make a career out of it,
like,
get out of there because they actually
just started because right now I'm used
to like kids soccer where they're just
running around chasing the ball.
It's cute.
It's fun.
It's fun to watch.
And uh,
and yeah,
my son just got into lacrosse and we
play catch with the lacrosse stick and
it's great.
We,
we have a good time playing catch with
it.
But no,
I haven't seen him getting about tennis,
men's soccer,
even soccer.
Which you think you know like who?
Who's getting hurt in soccer?
Soccer from heading the ball,
just heading the ball.
The ball flying at you,
hit it with your head.
Soccer are suffering from cte to the
point where they're starting to minimize
the amount of heading they do in
practices.
Really?
Yes.
This is what we're finding out about
brains like this is,
you know,
there's a good friend of mine,
Dr.
Mark Gordon who specializes in cte.
He deals with a lot of soldiers coming
back and a lot of them that are like my
friend andrew marr where they would blow
open doors so they'd set up a charge on
a door and step back and break the door.
Blow these guys.
I mean he didn't even get hit with
anything or maybe I add like that are
nearby.
Those guys suffer significant brain
damage and it's just from the impact of
just getting shook by an explosion.
Not even anything actually hitting them
in the head.
Which high school sport as the most
concussions.
Is it soccer girls,
soccer girls,
soccer.
Cheerleading had rates seen at boys
football by 2015.
Wow.
I know when you stop and you look at
those,
uh,
like when they're going to commercial
and the college game and they throw that
grew up in the air and you're like,
man,
to get that right.
I saw a documentary,
but it's one of the most dangerous
sports.
Sure.
This is high school cheerleading because
they do,
these girls fall on a gym floor.
I just smack their heads on the floor.
It's crazy.
There's a,
there's a,
um,
breakdancing,
instagram page called stance elements.
Jamie pullups dance elements is a guy
who looks like he's about 300 pounds and
he break dances.
He leaps forward and lands on the top of
his head and keeps his feet up in the
air.
I don't know how the fuck this guy did
this.
This guy's bigger than burt.
Really?
Yeah.
Maybe not as big.
Bird committee is pretty big and he
leaps forward and he's lands on his
head.
No hands lands on his head with his feet
up there and holds the position for like
a silent second is preposterous.
And when you can do that trick,
you look at this guy,
whoa.
Yeah.
Well,
the size of them,
oh my gosh,
this.
Give me some via
that guy.
We'll need a disc replacement within the
next month
is so much weight on your fucking head.
He's probably so dizzy and he's playing
it all.
Yeah,
no shit bro.
Look at that.
Oh,
I got to tell you,
you guys are making me feel so good
about my mostly sedentary lifestyle that
I've lived my whole life.
It's safer.
You're definitely don't.
Don't hit your head at this is coming
from somebody who watches people,
get their head hit for a living.
I'm feeling really good now.
Usually I feel more ashamed for the way
that I've been conducting myself.
It's just when you can avoid it.
I mean,
look,
it's not a bad way to make a living.
If you want to be a fighter and you
really want to do it and that's your
drive,
that you should do it,
but you should really learn how to
defend yourself correctly and learn the
right technique,
but when you're doing it for recreation
and you're doing something like the
cross where running at each other full
clip and smashing into each other,
and that's within the rules like I think
we're operating on ancient information.
That's what I think.
I think most of these systems that
they're setting up most of these,
these sports rules and a lot of the
organizations,
they're all operating on these old ideas
of brain damage.
That's why I'm freaking out when I'm
going to this school football game and
I'm watching this,
I'm like,
like this is just brain damage and brain
damage and then watching it.
That's promoted by a school and school
pride.
Yay.
Everybody go,
yeah,
yeah.
We're playing another team.
Let's hope we beat them.
How do you going to beat him?
You're going to fucking slam into them,
give them concussions and going to go to
school and they can't count.
Do you get blowback for talking about
that stuff or from fans and that kind of
thing?
No,
it's true.
Yeah.
I really,
I mean,
I'm sure there must be some blow back.
I don't read it anyway,
but it's got to be true.
I mean,
it's just too much evidence.
I just think you choose wisely choose.
They don't not take risks.
I mean if you really want to be a bmx
rider or a professional skateboarder,
you're going to take some knocks.
It's just part of the part of the
program.
Just don't,
don't do it if you don't have to.
Yeah,
because it,
it piles up and there's no coming back.
You know,
when you,
when you go in,
you have like significant brain damage.
I mean,
you can get therapy,
they can help you.
It can,
but you're,
you're gonna,
you're gonna be a road,
you're going down.
It's your brain.
I know they see the,
the.
I mean hbo is actually tapped into it a
lot with that real sports show for years
now.
They've been doing follow up pieces on
cte and men.
It is devastating to see some of those
guests.
Those guys are like in their fifties or
sixties and they're not there at all.
Dude.
I put a video up on instagram or on
twitter or retweeted it and it's boxers
where it shows the boxers when they're
young and they're talking and then it
shows them like at the end of their
career they're retiring.
And then In the interview them and you
see them,
like,
just completely gone,
like a shell
interview with riddIck bowe really bad.
Oh,
it's awful.
And I remember even at this one was
actually kind of funny.
Was a james tony.
Hm.
Because he was,
hE was,
uh,
It was towards the end of his fighting
and he was definitely at least 40 pounds
overweight,
right?
Like really out of shape but still
throwing bombs and he was sparring and
it was like that piece that they air
right before the fighters go to the ring
for the,
on fight night.
And I mean he's definitely taken some
shots and given some shots,
but he was sparring and they were
throwing in fresh bodies for him to spar
against.
So it was like,
you know,
two mInutes with this guy.
And then boom,
fresh body and as he's lIke,
he is like really hyperventilation spit
and
he's still talking shit like at,
as he's fighting,
he's like blah blah.
And just.
And then they bring in the guys like
your mom,
he just,
he's a mess.
It looks like a total mess,
but he's just like talking shit,
calling guys shit.
Like as he's barely making it through
these,
these sparring sessions and you know,
I mean he,
he needs.
But he's one of those guys he had to
fight.
He had to fight.
Well,
especially towards the end of his
career,
he took a fight in the ufc.
He did?
Yeah.
He's the only like real world champ
peon boxer that ever fought in mixed
martial arts and the ufc and randy
couture ankle picked him,
took him down,
strangled them right away.
Yeah.
It was easy.
I mean there's just,
you know,
he,
I don't even think he really bothered
learning talking to tony.
I think he just put the gloves on and
got In there and just had no idea what
to do.
When randy got ahold of him,
he was clearly untrained when it came to
the gravity of this low ankle,
low single.
I mean this is the beginning of the
fight.
Randy just immediately mount some
punches him in the head a bunch of times
and then strangled them and you know,
randy was just honestly being nice.
Really?
Yeah.
He could have punished them a lot longer
if you want it to.
He just wanted to finish them up.
It was sad because it was just,
it,
you know,
he was talking about all these guys just
don't know how to handle his hands and
every fight starts standing up and which
is true.
But randy coture will take you down all
day anytime he wants.
And then he got him in an arm triangle,
just smushed them.
I mean,
even when he's punching him,
he's not even hitting him that hard
here.
He's just trying to force them to give
something up.
That's what he wants.
He wants his head tied down against the
side of his arm and he's going to squish
them.
And as you tap,
that's it.
It's wrap.
didn't take apart.
It was pretty quick.
That was pretty fast.
And james,
tony's one of the best that ever did it
a phenomenal boxer,
but just need.
I talked to a lot of shit.
It was shit talker.
Yeah.
So I don't want to discourage you,
but.
No,
no,
no.
this is you show your son.
So these videos,
because we're out in the backyard
playing catch,
it's just like a slice of America.
They're not even thinking about this.
People operate not totally aware of
consequences and they make choices that
will affect them for the rest of their
lives.
Yes.
That's what I mean.
I love my job.
I mean you guys are kind of like,
I'm having that feeling right now
because I love my kids so much.
I think.
Oh wow.
Basketball?
Yeah,
he does.
Yeah.
Basketball's a great support.
There's no no contact and guaranteed
contracts,
man.
if you mentioned the best,
how tall is he?
Not tom.
Yeah.
Okay.
What about baseball?
It's another one.
Baseball.
Baseball is the bomb.
Diggity.
As long as you only hit a bit of pitch,
you'd hit with a pitch that than that.
That's the lifestyle,
man.
I don't know if I'm allowed to do this
here,
but while we're here I really wanted to
talk about how tom got into this movie
and we talk about that.
What do you mean allowed to just like
totally like,
you know,
jump,
jump tracks like that and just throw in
rules podcast.
Yeah.
How did he get into this?
How did I get into this?
So,
so I,
I saw stand up and I thought I thought
it was really funny and we had already
written a draft of the script and I was
like,
oh man,
this guy would,
would be a great russ.
And I didn't really think too much about
it because we were making another movie
at the time.
And then when it came back around we
were talking about,
you know,
just talking about different people that
you're going to cast and you get these
boards up and see your picture was
actually on a board for a while.
Wow.
I don't think you even knew that.
I didn't know that picture was on a
board.
I did not know that.
And uh,
so then,
um,
so tell it from your angle when you got
the call though,
because I'll tell you this,
so I didn't know if you,
I don't even know if you know this,
that I passed on the audition.
I do,
yeah.
Yeah,
a good.
So when they,
you know,
for people like when you're,
if you're a star,
you get calls that like you have an
offer,
right?
Like you want this off,
do you want to do this movie?
But if you're just working,
trying to get booked,
you get these emails.
Usually it's an email followed by a call
that says like a,
for your consideration,
um,
movies called family.
Uh,
sean and there's,
John Morris wrote it.
It's uh,
you know,
the part is russ and it has like all
the,
you know,
mark walberg agreed to play this in rose
byrne is attached to play this and then
here's the sides.
And it was like one of those things
where it'll say,
you know,
so thursday at 11,
15:00
AM,
you are confirmed for the audition and I
get that email like on a monday.
And I was like,
I just got back from the road,
I'll say I've got a podcast today.
I was like,
whatever.
And then I just don't even read any of
it.
So then it's like,
you know,
tuesday and then something happens and
we're busy at the house and then went
and then they go here,
we're just following up that you're good
for the audition tomorrow.
I get that like on wednesday,
you know,
just confirming that you'll be there.
And I were like,
nah,
like that's a pass,
like I'm not going to be there.
And that was it.
I just sent that off.
Like I'm just not doing that this week.
And then I get a call right away and
it's my agent,
he's like,
hey,
uh,
I noticed that you trying to make money
off.
I noticed that you're not going to,
you said no.
Is there a reason?
Did the,
uh,
what did they say?
There's always that phrase,
did you respond to the site?
Did you not respond to the material,
the material?
And I go,
oh,
I haven't even read it.
And they go,
well why aren't you reading it?
I was like,
because and I just kind of lay out my
week.
I'm like,
I've had this,
I've had this with my kid,
I traveled,
I'm doing this.
I just got a lot going on.
And they're like,
he's like,
okay,
I go.
So like,
it's not personal.
I think like he's taking it personal.
I go,
I'm not saying no to upset you,
I just have these things.
And he's like,
okay,
well the director specifically requested
that you audition and like,
as you know,
that doesn't happen a lot with you.
So like do you want to reconsider?
And I was like,
yeah,
hold on.
I go.
He asked me,
he's asking for me to be like,
yeah,
and I go,
did you believe him or did you think it
was relating you?
I did.
I did believe him because I mean he's
never said that.
And um,
you know,
a lot of times I've done things with
like the producers are in the room on
this session or that stuff.
And I go,
okay,
well here's the deal man.
I'm not going to go in unprepared.
So because now it's like the auditions
in 24 hours,
so I go,
I'll do it,
but you have to buy me a couple more
days because I'm like,
I have this the rest of today,
like I'm not going to do it tomorrow
morning.
And he was like,
okay,
I'll see what I can do.
And then he called me back.
He's like,
they said they're good for monday or
whatever,
and I was like,
great.
So and then I,
then I tried to prepare for that,
like,
you know,
because they told me the director
requests.
I was like,
I can't go into this thing half fast.
So then I'm like really trying to
prepare for that and then I go in there
and it was you,
you're on skype.
well okay,
so here's what happened from my end
because you didn't show up.
Show up.
I had to go back to atlanta.
And so then we had to do the audition
via skype.
What I see,
I didn't know that.
That's brutaL for it.
Everybody else,
because you didn't show up,
but who organize it?
What kind of nonsense agency are you
with that they booked you something and
don't tell you that they book?
well,
they always do that where they'll just
book it.
No,
they'll,
they'll set up a time,
right?
Like it's very common.
will they'll go 11:00
AM 11:00
AM your agency?
Yes.
Now they must have nothing to do with
your podcast then nothing.
That's the problem,
right?
Yeah.
So they don't know what you're booking.
So they just think that that takes
precedent.
They also will be like,
hey,
you have an audition friday and I'm
like,
when I'm in philadelphia and they're
you're in philadelphia.
Is there any way you can move that
agency for your standup as well?
Oh christ.
Is there any way you can move that?
They really fucking say that.
Oh yeah.
They had an agent tell you,
let me call these 5,000
people that are waiting.
I had an agent,
I had an agent go,
like,
why don't you just,
um,
oh,
it was about like bookings on booking.
And I was like,
when does it shoot though?
Like if I booked this,
when does it shoot?
And it was like this,
you know,
October 3rd or whatever.
I'm like,
oh,
but I'm in sacramento.
And he was like,
just move that.
And I was like,
yeah,
but it's to theater shows.
It's like 5,000
people.
And he was like,
oh really?
I'm like,
yeah,
like you think I just got to.
Yeah,
just move It aside.
And he's like,
I'm like,
why don't you know that my calendar is
public?
Just look it up man.
But yeah,
they'll give you answers like that.
So she quit acting.
It's should make this movie,
this movie is going to be awesome.
Make it your
swan song,
bro.
A lot of people are saying it's the
breakout performance of the year.
I don't know if You've heard of crackle,
their resume,
If they do whatever they do.
Well,
so I'm in,
I'm in atlanta,
atlanta,
thank you.
And uh,
I.
And he,
he additions via skype and what I saw
his standup,
I was like,
this guy is perfect because we want this
guy to just have this kind of swagger
and this confidence.
But he can kind of say these jackasses
things,
but just sort of own them.
and I'm like,
this guy,
this guy's perfect for this.
I keep saying this guy because I didn't
know him at the time.
And uh,
so tom comes in and I watched the skype
audition,
now I'm going to shit talk you a little
bit here and a.
And he was not good.
He was so not like,
like who he is.
Like he came in and he kind of was like
sort of putting us back into it a little
bit.
Like he was kind of like really just
trying to be kind of like really sort of
extra funny and it was just not at all
what I had in mind,
but I just was like,
so I,
so I'm watching it skype and I'm just.
So I'm,
I'm trying to give,
you know,
somebody that you weren't good and I
have,
I had no idea what,
what,
whether it.
Here's the thing,
everY audition,
this is actually fascinating if you
audition because you literally leave
auditions and you go,
sometimes you go,
that was great and you'll never hear
anything again.
Sometimes you go,
I bombed,
and you get a call.
Hey,
guess what?
They want to see you again.
Are you like,
you don't know what they want?
No idea.
You have no idea.
I don't really know what they want when
you're going in.
I did not know that.
It sucked that bad.
I didn't know that.
It didn't know it wasn't that it that it
sucked that bad it.
It might've been.
No,
no it wasn't.
it was just that you,
you have this very specific thing that
you do that I wanted to bring in and be
a part of this character.
And you left that out.
See I.
But I don't think.
What's that thing?
It's like he's got this,
he's got this in his delivery.
This kind of devil may care.
Kind of like dead pan sort of,
but it's this,
but it's,
it's,
it's like a big part of your persona is
this whole like,
all right,
whatever.
I just said that.
okay.
And I,
I wanted russ to have that thing.
And when you came into to audition,
you left that thing out.
I think I did that in the movie.
Not at all.
No.
You were great in the movie.
No,
I'm saying I feel like I did the movie
exactly how I audition.
No,
you didn't at all really know.
It was like night and day.
Really.
Night and day.
In my mind if you,
if someone were to ask me,
I'd be like 100 percent of the sentence.
the second audition you did just like
the movie.
Really?
Yeah.
Because basically so,
so then what happened is we got together
and I thought and I was like,
god,
I don't want to meet him for the second
audition.
Well then what?
We got together because I called them
because I really wanted him to be at the
movie and I called him and I said,
would you be willing to come over to my
house and we can just talk through it
and work through it.
A little desk.
That's what harvey weinsteIn shit.
I made jokes about that.
I made jokes about that immediately to
him on the phone.
I was like,
am I going to give you a bath?
He was like,
all right,
can I tell you I got to go back.
This is more embarrassing.
I remember leaving that audition that
now you're telling me this,
the first one and tell my agent like
there's no way I could've done better.
I did tell him that.
I was like,
there's no.
I could not.
I don't,
I can't imagine.
Dude,
I'm serious.
That's the thing.
I,
I understand that because you have
energy and you were funny,
but you just didn't have that thing that
I wanted so badly to be a part of this
character.
And,
and so it was,
there was this one thing that was
missing and then you came over and we
talked about it and then you did it.
And then also we got the chance to.
Because we didn't,
when he read it,
he's just reading dialogue that we wrote
for anybody.
But then once you,
once you have somebody's voice in your
head a little bit,
you can adjust it and make it a little
more comfortable.
So we,
we,
we made some adjustments to the dialogue
and everything which made it more
conducive to your style of speaking
cadence.
Yeah.
That was fun.
And uh,
yeah,
it was.
And so then he comes back and he does it
again and he crushed it and he was
really funny and we sent that to the
studio and they were like,
oh my god,
this guy's great.
And it was like such a no idea.
I have no idea.
That's kind of what I wanted to talk
about this on the podcast because I knew
you didn't know all.
I definitely didn't know that.
It's actually like,
it's,
it's the thing though,
like if that's the big bummer about in
general auditioning is you walk out and
you go,
sometimes you follow up with your agent
and you're like,
what?
So what's the feedback?
And they're like,
ah,
they look,
they always,
they always tell you they loved you and
you're like,
is there anything else you don't know?
Like was it good,
was it bad?
And you also don't know what they're
looking for.
And I don't know.
I mean go into your place.
I'm going over like,
you know,
in detail more is also like,
I actually felt like I won a contest
because you audition now I know I
tanked.
And then the directors like do you want
to come work on it so that like possibly
you can do it better?
And I was like sure man.
So I'm,
I'm working with him on this thing and I
don't know,
we spent a lot of time working on it and
then when I found out I booked the role,
then I go there and I feel like it's a
second part of the contest because like
he has all great actors in the movie.
Like for all of the parts.
I mean you know the stars,
but like margo martindale from the
american.
You're watching americans know that
shows.
You've seen her though.
She's amazing.
She's one heard that shows awesome.
That shows so good.
I mean it just ended.
But like if you ever want to go on a
binge weekend,
now you have like six seasons I think to
go through and she,
I,
I became a big fan of hers on that.
And then julie haggerty and you have
like all these great actors.
So every time spencer take notaro we had
like really good.
Every time we're shooting a scene with
one of the,
with one of them,
I ended up just watching them like I'm
in the scene and I'm just like,
wow,
she's a really good actor.
That's weird,
isn't it?
Yeah,
totally is.
I did a scene with maura tierney once
when I was on newsradio.
Maura tierney is definitely one of the
best actors I've ever worked with,
but she was so good that she did the
law.
We're were rehearsing,
doing all this things.
She did the lion in the scene and I
didn't realize that it was the lion from
the scene.
I realized she was just talking.
I thought she was just talking because
of how like she's so natural.
I was like,
that kind of creeped me out.
oh,
that's the line.
That was weird.
yeah,
totally normal.
Right?
Because otherwise people like tom,
where are we going to find a guy that's
going to fix that?
So forth.
She had none of that because she was
really an actor before she was.
I would just say some of them don't like
to be called actresses.
Right?
yeah.
So it's safer to say actor,
but it comics could see who the fuck
uses comedian remember that?
That went away.
I didn't know that doesn't exist
anymore.
You know about the latin x thing.
I didn't know that was the thing.
We didn't know about that.
What do you mean?
I was reading this article and yeah,
it's and latina are male and female.
Gender specific.
So the,
And the word latin also get,
gets it done as far as.
Yeah,
I dunno.
Yeah.
So it's supposed to be like that's how
you latin x,
you should say that you're supposed to
say latinex because it's just new.
It's not,
it's a couple years in the making and
fuck off.
We'll see in spanish.
the masculinized version of these words
just considered gender neutral,
but that obviously doesn't work for some
of us like myself.
And so I think it's appropriate to
assign a masculinity as gender neutral
when it isn't.
So I'm latinex well it's interesting
because my kids are latin and this is
another one of the things that we touch
on to next.
Yeah,
there it is and we touch it.
Oh,
sorry,
go ahead.
No,
go ahead,
please.
Well,
we touch on this a little,
not this pronunciation or you know,
but we touch on that a little bit in the
movie of there is that feeling,
you know,
when,
when we went in to adopt our kids,
we were just open.
We were like,
look,
we're,
we're pretty general age wise,
we didn't go in expecting three kids.
Just,
you know,
we thought one and it sort of turned
into that.
But uh,
but you know,
you're open to it and you're just there
and they ask you,
well,
what about ethnIcity?
You know,
and just go,
yeah,
whatever,
you know,
wherever the need is,
whoever needs parents let us know.
And,
but then when,
when it happens and your kids in my,
in my case,
my kids turned out to be latin,
then you have the,
you know,
you start to kind of think about like,
oh,
well,
you know,
uh,
is that,
is that okay?
Is that gonna?
Is that gonna look like the white savior
thing?
Is that going to look weird?
Is that am I,
am I saying things right?
And whatever.
And what ends up happening is this
really wonderful thing where your family
becomes this melting pot where,
you know,
at first,
because of the,
the,
the times that we live in right now,
it is,
it's a little scary jumping into that
because thinking about what you know,
but you're,
you know,
but you ultimately are just going to
think about who the kids are,
what their need is and how wonderful
they are and,
but you.
But all of those things come up and
that's the kind of thing that wouldn't
even be,
you know,
why would that the,
the latinex thing have anything to do
with my house.
Well now it does.
Yeah.
So I've got,
I've got all that,
you know,
all the time.
And,
and uh,
I actually find it really interesting
latinex thing.
No,
no,
not that specifically,
but just that,
that my family is now this little
melting pot.
Yeah,
that part's cool.
And it's cool.
I reject latinex completely.
Well,
it is,
it is cool.
But it's also very strange that that is
a.
And it would be a real point of concern,
like you would worry about how do I
handle this new culture without cultural
appropriation,
how do I,
how do I bring my kid and embrace the
latino or latina culture?
Like what do I,
how do I handle that?
Yeah.
And how do we do it without getting
called a racist?
Right.
And it gets back to what I was talking
about before where you're trying to just
put your kids' needs first and just deal
with them as children,
as individuals,
as human beings,
you know,
and,
but at the same time you're also,
you're with other parents and there's in
the adoption community and really in
every direction,
there's mixed race families and the
adoption community and uh,
and you're kind of learning from them.
And it just,
I don't know,
it just,
it opens up a lot of conversations with
your own kids and,
and just the movies.
You watch the foods you eat sometimes.
And I,
I don't,
I think it's great.
No,
it's great.
I think it's really,
you know,
the,
uh,
the language thing,
for me,
it stands out more because my whole life
I've said latIno,
like my mother's latina and it's just
funny to me to speak spanish.
He speaks fluently,
which is hilarious because tom has some
great stories about people not thinking
he speaks spanish because when you look
at them you're like,
oh,
this fucking american guy.
It looks like a regular american guy.
but he speaks perfect.
I've been around him before when he
asked people questions,
like,
oh,
I forgot you could do that.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's like someone who,
you know,
they could do backflips,
right?
Just do a backflip,
be like,
oh,
I forgot you could do that.
Yeah,
it's true.
And that throw it throws people off
because you look so american.
Yeah.
And that,
you mean you look like a guy.
I mean if you have a guy who loves
football,
like it's still fucking american,
a regular american,
but he speaks perfect.
He rOlls the.
When you go.
Even when I travel abroad to spanish
speaking countries,
even there,
even though spanish speaking countries
are also melting pot different,
they still look at you like,
oh shit,
look at this motherfucker.
It's really throws people at the most.
The craziest one wasn't even with me and
my sister who,
one of my sisters who also speak
spanish,
uh,
went to the naval academy's linguistics
center,
so in the navy and she was in the navy
for awhile and she learned mandarin and
it was really,
really
intense.
And we went to a restaurant together and
the guy who was one of those,
like a benihana tight where they chop
stuff up and the guy was a,
someone asked like where he's from and
he said somewhere in China and she
started speaking mandarin and he dropped
the thing and he was like,
he saw a ghost and she's spitting back
to them and pretty fluent mandarin and
he stops.
And he was like,
I've never seen this before.
And he's like,
I've never seen a white person do this.
And we were like,
yeah,
pretty,
pretty wild.
And then he turned us.
He goes,
I don't think you understand how hard it
is to speak this language,
and I was like,
I have a pretty good idea,
I can't do it.
And then just watching it,
he was just like,
he couldn't even start cooking except
your sister to learn.
Um,
well she was in.
When you sign,
when you get into like that naval
institute program,
they have you going,
I think it was something like eight
hours a day,
five or six days a week.
So it's really,
it's super into,
it's almost like learning mandarin.
Yeah.
And it overwhelms people.
People drop out almost like in a
physical stress way,
you know,
some people just can't handle the camp
like bootcamp and I forget how long she
was in and you know,
she didn't reach the level of I'm super
fluent,
like we're speaking english,
but she was able to communicate in
mandarin.
Can she read it?
She was reading and writing.
That's the thing is she was telling me
one time about how many characters and
you know,
it was just unbelievable and like
there's sounds for expressions like I'm
going to screw up [inaudible] I don't
remember it,
but she was like,
you can do something like,
oh,
and that means like means an actual
phrase,
you know,
like there's so many and that,
uh,
that there's characters that mean entire
expressions as well,
that I was like,
this is just,
our brains are so married to our
alphabet and way of speaking that it's a
real jump to,
to learn that,
you know,
it's just,
it really is fascinating when you travel
and you listen to people speaking their
native tongue and you realize how
strangely different languages are across
the entire planet.
Just unbelievable.
I was in Thailand thIs summer and you
listen to people talk,
tie and everything.
Everything stretches.
It's got like a stretch to it,
you know,
it's like a weird.
It's very odd language.
I'm like,
compare that to like german or dutch,
like the germans got those hard sounding
really hard.
it's like this weird difference.
Yeah.
And the latin one,
latin root word,
like languages all do have a flowy
singing sounds kind of nice to listen to
the language.
That's really nice.
I've met like listening.
I don't speak portuguese.
I like listening to it.
Yeah,
brazilian portuguese is amazing.
Sounds so cool.
And I listened to.
We listened to french music sometimes at
home.
Just in the kitchen.
Yeah.
Like cooking or something.
I don't know.
What the hell are you saying?
I like it when I write.
I listen to spanish music when I write
because I have no idea what they're
saying.
I did that to you listen to music in a
foreign language so that it doesn't.
It doesn't.
It doesn't distract.
Yeah.
It's like,
it sounds good.
It gives me a little something,
something.
But I can still think about the exact
things that I'm thinking about.
Well,
I recently had this interesting
experience.
I sent you one of them that,
you know,
the trailers for the movie get a.
Oh yeah.
The movie itself and the trailers get
dubbed into all kinds of different
languages.
So you have this dialogue that,
that I wrote or meeting town road or
whatever,
and you get to hear it in these
different languages and I sent you the
Spain spanish because that's different
and I don't really,
I'm not going to pretend that I
understand that much.
What the difference between the,
between it is.
But that's predominantlY what you speak,
right?
No,
no it isn't.
not mother What I speak predominantly it
was just like specifically south
american and more specifically a
peruvian.
Okay.
All right,
great.
So,
but I mean I did study,
I studied in madrid for six months and
once your,
your ears are trained to it,
you can listen to someone say a sentence
and know that it's,
oh,
that's from Spain.
Like,
that's,
that's really interesting.
Then there's the cuban version of it,
which is crazy.
Yeah.
Version of the way they,
all the island dialects sound
dramatically different,
you know,
like if you listen to somebody from
Cuba,
puerto rico,
is it a comparison like english speakers
from America versus english speakers
from Ireland?
[inaudible]?
It is,
yeah.
Um,
and I would say,
you know,
I always think of Spain as like our
britain,
you know,
in a way like the language properly
english is from england.
That's where the language,
that is,
how you speak it spanish and a guest to
yet castilian that comes from Spain.
They're speaking oji spanish and then it
all kind of came over here and it's
influenced and every country has
different ways of saying things
different.
Obviously different slAng,
um,
all different curses,
all different expressions,
completely different.
Even words like as simple as like to
pick up,
you know,
go ahead,
pick something up.
You know,
you say that in Mexico or Argentina,
it literally means to fuck.
So really?
Yeah.
So if you're like know cuticle hair
style,
like you're trying to,
you're saying like,
I want to fuck this water?
Yeah,
but I'm going to fuck this bottle.
yeah.
My mom told me that she was In a,
in Argentina,
like when her youth and traveled there
and was with a bell hop and she was
like,
go ahead man,
I'm on.
Which is like,
pick up that suitcase.
But he was like,
okay,
because she was basically in slang
saying fuck my suitcase,
you know,
so it's just.
But like,
there's like,
there's also like severity of words,
like hold aid is the word,
like there's so many ways to say fuck
you,
of course,
in every language.
But khaled in Spain is like saying fuck.
It's like going like,
oh fuck.
But like when you say it in Peru,
nomi has,
it's a,
it's a softer.
It's not taken as severely.
So it's not,
it's not read the same way.
You're not saying you're saying,
uh,
like you're complaining,
but you're like,
I don't.
It's like,
it's taken as like,
oh,
don't mess with me,
you know?
So like,
even when I would say when I would go to
Spain,
they were like,
damn,
you curse a lot.
And I was like,
really?
And then they,
you know,
we went over that one and then like six
months later they were like,
you actually do curse a lot all the
time.
And I was like,
yeah,
that's probably right.
Do you do stand up in spanish when you.
I've done bits and stories were like,
I involve both english and spanish,
but I haven't done theirs.
There's a show now I'm here in la that
they're doing a thing that even at the
stores had it like once where,
uh,
some of the spanish speaking comics
here,
um,
have done like a full show in spanish
here in la.
Francisco ramos of felipe.
I did it as far as uh,
um,
well,
what's the other guy?
Torres.
joey do it.
I don't know if joey did it.
Joe used to do spanglish and in miami he
would do cuban spanish plus english and
it was impossible to follow because of
the audiences were,
there's so many cuban people in the
audience and he would hit punch lines in
spanish and people would literally just
throw chairs through windows and jumped
through the cla people where he would
crush.
So I middled once in miami.
And did you know,
you used every trick and to get through
the sex.
It's such a chaotic club because I
wasn't saying it was totally insane and
I was doing stuff and talking to this
lady.
I would,
you know,
I would hit a punchline in spanish and
then say something back to this guy's
spanish,
then go back to english,
do like your best bit and then something
else is spanish and it was so crazy for
me at the time,
like I never experienced a 20 minute set
like that,
that the guy,
the headline or after we did 35 minutes
and split like he was just like a good
night because it was,
he was a white guy and was like not know
what's happening once they got that
flavor.
Yeah.
Because it was like,
it's the most.
I mean that,
that room that didn't hold that many
people had like 300 I think last I think
probably less,
maybe like 75 or something and it had
like,
you know,
they were haitians in there,
colombians,
cubans,
puerto rican.
But I mean it was such a mix of people
and they,
if you start giving them a little bit of
flavor.
Yeah.
And they let people in there that were
like 18 to 18 people in with guns and
all kinds of people.
It was a the miami improv.
It was the the worst club to work.
They're reopening in a new location.
Good luck.
Yeah,
too late.
I dunno.
I know.
That was a.
What was it that was coconut grove and
now they're opening I think in doral,
in miami.
Just so crazy.
It's such an interesting place.
It's so different than any other place.
I did miami right before I did my
netflix special and they were using
those yonder bags.
We had to put your cell phone into
yonder bag so you couldn't use it while
you were inside the store,
so you know what they did.
You could leave the room and use the
yonder bag.
Right.
So these,
the entire set,
it was the only place where the entire
set people just kept coming and going.
They just kept leaving and coming back
there was so many people doing it and it
might've been like dozens of people at
any point in time walking around,
coming and going to,
going outside to get to use their phone
and then coming back in like it was
chaos.
The phone thing.
I don't know that there's a real good
solution yet,
but I did the yonder thing in new
orleans and that place wasn't too big,
but it was,
it was still.
You could tell like,
you know,
it's inconvenient for them.
It's a,
it's a long thing to go thRough that,
but then you're like,
then you have people coming and going in
and out of the showroom because they
want to use their phone.
It's a fucking nightmare,
but if they don't,
if they just sit there and just tune
into the show,
it's great.
It's like 10 percent better.
I think so too.
Yeah,
but it's hard.
It's hard to impose that on people too
and a surprised when people don't know.
They're like,
I'm doing what with my phone man.
Going to put it in a bag.
It's still going to be on you and you
can use it as long as you leave this
room.
They're like,
out of,
no man,
I need to check my phone every 18
seconds.
Yeah.
I had to let people know,
but there's some people that just want
to film everything to,
you know when you get on stage,
you see people just stand there while
you're doing your set and they're
holding a phone up you and you're like,
this is.
You're making this whole thing so much
weirder.
Yeah.
Do you understand what you're doing?
You're basically like a tmz guy at the
airport,
like they're watching a show,
like holding it up in front of them like
they're not even looking at for comedy
too.
I went to of all things a daddy daughter
dance with my daughter and it was the
weirdest thing.
Every guy was dancing with their little
kids like this and I realized,
I realized that why they were doing it.
It wasn't about the moment,
I mean a little bit,
but it was more about that that if you
have that phone out and you're looking
at that screen and you're doing that,
it sort of keeps everything else out.
It makes you feel like you're having
this little moment instead of having to
be this awkward thing of like you're
dancing in front of these other grown
men.
I think it's done.
Honestly.
I think you're just trying to capture
these moments.
You know,
you're,
you're painfully aware that they're only
going to be six for a year.
Yeah.
but not all night.
You know what I mean?
Because that's the problem is that you
wind up as a parent,
you wind up with all this video that
you,
that you're never going to watch because
it's.
But you're thinking logicAlly.
Yeah.
Maybe people aren't.
They're just collecting video,
you know,
they're just collecting their,
like hoarders.
Well,
the thing that made me think of it
though is that I was more comfortable
when I had the phone on.
I was like,
oh yeah,
because I like,
I'm doing something,
like I'm not just dancing,
like if I'm just doing this thing I'm
doing like a,
like a parental kind of thing.
I'm just documenting my cute kid.
But then when I put the phone away I
felt a lot more exposed.
But like,
okay,
why?
I thought it was painful for everybody
that dance doing my ah,
it's,
oh,
it's terrible.
and every guy there had the same,
had the same feeling,
I'm sure.
So.
But I was just like,
nope,
I'm not going to do it.
I'm putting my phone away.
This is stupid.
And tell you what though,
man,
you go back and look at those videos
from when your kid was really little and
it does freak you out.
Like they're,
they're really valuable.
Powerful videos.
Yeah.
Videos of your kids when they're really
young.
They're so,
there's a video of my daughter when she
was,
she was wearing a diaper,
I think she was probably just a little
over one and we're walking through the
airport and I'm pulling a,
uh,
one of those little roller bags and
she's,
she's behind it,
pushing it.
She liked to push it on her legs like
that tall and a little diaper butt and
me pushing this thing and we tell her,
hey,
we're going to go to a toy store.
And she's like,
oh.
And she puts her hands together and she
pushes the bag in.
But it's like the most adorable.
My watched that video hundred times
easier.
Yeah.
It's like that video will forever be
stained in my brain.
That's crazy mode.
We've got these videos too.
There's an inch.
There's a really interesting thing.
We were starting to get there earlier in
our conversation,
but there's an interesting thing that
happens when you adopt kids,
particularly kids that are already
walking and talking when they come into
your life.
You go through this really chaotic
adjustment period because nobody knows
each other and it's very.
It's just.
it's just so awkward for everybody
involved and and there's.
There's a,
there's so much to it,
but it's a reallY difficult time for
everybody,
but then when you have that,
when you get on the other side of it and
he really falling in love with your kids
and you could feel that they're falling
in love with you and you're becoming
this family.
We have these videos.
We went on this trip back to Wisconsin
where I'm from and when we were just.
Things were really starting to come
together before this trip and then when
we went on the trip,
the kids like you're describing the kid
pushing the suitcase,
like they have to stay a little tighter
with you because you're in airports and
you're and you're driving and you're
going to like a cabin and doing these
things and by the time we got back we
were a family.
Like we knew my wife and I were like,
wow,
we're,
we're like a real family now.
Like we love these kids so much and we
can tell they love us and it's an
amazing thing.
So we have videos from that trip and
those videos like you're saying,
or just like gold,
you know,
it's so amazing to see this phone
number,
the bonding.
That's got to be such an intense feeling
to,
to realize that these kids could have
gone in some terrible direction.
I mean they could.
When you're six years old,
you're,
you're.
So,
anything can happen.
Anything can go wrong.
And instead they got so lucky and they
found you.
I mean,
it's like what an incredibly positive
thing that is,
that you've done an incredibly
positive thing for their lives that they
came in contact with you.
And so fortunate,
I mean,
it's amazing,
but for our lives too,
and we didn't know it for a while,
you know,
we had that period where we were like,
you really feel like for awhile they're
like,
okay,
we've,
we've done a good thing here and we're
going to suffer for it for the rest of
our lives.
And then.
But then as it comes online,
I had this one more,
I think I told you this,
but I had this one moment that,
and I'm not this kind of guy,
I don't think of myself as this kind of
guy,
but after all of this,
just frustration and craziness and,
and uh,
the kids would wake up really early
every morning and they would be out in
the hallway throwing things at each
other and arguing and whatever.
And you,
you're so sleep deprived and you're
just.
So like the overheads.
And one morning I woke up,
I think it was a sunday and it was quiet
in the room,
my wife was still asleep and it was like
around the time where the kids are
normally up and I woke up and I thought,
oh wow,
it's quiet in here.
And then I had this just overwhelming
feeling that I couldn't even identify it
first.
and then I thought,
oh shit,
I missed them right now.
Like I'm actually waiting for them to
come in the room and wake us up.
And that was,
that was really a big moment for me
where I was like,
wow,
I've turned a big corner here and that
what you get from them and that,
those kinds of feelings is pretty
incredible.
Is this strange scene in the movie,
like thinking that this is based on not
just your life experience but also based
on your interaction with some kids that
you never wanted up adopting?
Yeah,
it's.
Well and also I met a,
but like I said,
I've met a bunch of families along the
waY and some of the.
There's this young girl named Maria
Green who became a consultant on the
movie because she grew up in foster
care.
She was adopted as a teenager.
She's amazIng kid.
She goes to ucla right now and uh,
and so I know either my own stories or
other people's stories.
I can associate them with really
specific kids.
So the thing that's embarrassing is that
I'm taking the movie all over the
country and I've seen the movie like a
thousand times now.
And anytime I watch it with an audience,
I get emotional watching the movie.
I mean the movie is really funny,
but it's got some really emotional
moments and it's embarrassing because it
looks like,
oh good.
So broken up by my,
my own movie,
but it's.
But it's really because I'm thinking
about my own kids or I'm thinking about
these,
these real kids that are,
you know,
that I've met along the way.
So it's,
it's pretty good.
I got to tell you this,
that I know I'm in it and I'm amazing in
it,
but I'm saying I'm saying,
uh,
in the.
We went to the screening like a month or
two ago and christina and I,
uh,
get there and we run into mark right
away.
So he's like,
he's like,
you haven't seen this?
And I go,
no.
He's like,
it's really men.
It's really good.
And I was like,
yeah,
I keep hearing it's good.
And he's like,
no.
Like he was like,
he was prepping me for how emotional he
gets in it.
He goes,
he's like,
ah,
you know,
I,
I've,
I've been some violent stuff that's
awesome,
but this,
I'm in and he's like,
I couldn't help but like get emotional
about it.
And I was like,
okay.
I'm like,
all right.
and then I sit there and watch and then
I look over seeing this crying and parts
of the movie.
I start getting emotional person.
But I mean it's like he actually says
you,
you did a really good job of balancing
those emotional moments with the comedy.
So,
I mean,
I don't know how you do it,
but like the,
the back and forth of it was like a
perfect balance.
And I think it's,
um,
it's a great movie.
I mean,
everybody who's seen it has,
you know that has said anything to me is
just like blown away by the movie.
Yeah,
that.
Well,
and that balance of comedy and drama was
what we worked on.
that was the number one thing we worked
on through every draft of everything and
it's great and it is really fun to watch
with an audience because they do get
emotionally caught up in it,
but we're always coming back and giving
them a laugh where they need it.
You know,
and this is a hit.
Do you think they're going to want to
dig down to other aspects of your
personal life to pull out this is all I
got.
This is bluestar airlines for me,
this is what does bluestar airlines in
wall street when charlie sheen couldn't
sell anything to gordon gekko and then
he's like,
well what about bluestar lines?
Because he had the tip from his dad
because his dad was a mechanic at blue
star alliance.
That's been kind of the running joke
that this is the only interesting thing
in my life.
I've Already gone there and It's just,
you know,
when this.
When this happens,
you know,
and you,
you become part of that adoption
community as well,
so it really becomes a big part of who
you are and who your family is and that
kind of thing.
so you know,
this is all I got.
I got this.
And then making movies.
This must be a different movie for you
though.
I mean you,
I'm sure you love your other movies,
but this one's going to be a really
different fits.
It's really different because I,
you know,
I was talking about sex drive before and
the reason why that one was a special
place in my heart is because it was my
first real hollywood movie and I was
just,
it,
it's,
it was just such an amazing experience
to just be this bumpkin from out of
nowhere making this movie with all this
budget and it was great.
But I've had great experiences on all
the movies that I've made,
but this one is totally different.
It's a different tone.
It has more drama,
it has more gravity to it.
It's about something that is really,
really important to me and it.
And it's really funny and we have people
like tom and the movIe and tom is,
I mean,
you know,
we're joking,
but he is really funny in the movie.
I believe you.
It was funny.
He's a funny guy.
Yeah,
he's a fun.
I really do.
Thanks ben.
Telling people that for years.
But I haven't been lying.
It was fun to do men.
It was really a thrill.
We just became one of those.
No,
but I'll tell you this though.
The comradery on that thing was another
thing that was really fun because you go
to a different.
We went to atlanta and we have this
great group every day where we have
like,
you know,
you have the big stars.
But then like people I mentioned like
margo and then uh,
and julie,
michael,
allen,
brit,
jodie.
And we would just like,
it was like,
it is kind of like being in a camp or
something,
which for me was the first experience
you
don't know is that.
And what a lot of people who work in
movies a lot of times that,
that so much of the,
the um,
the comradery of the set is set by kind
of number one,
number two on the call sheet,
like whoever the big movie stars are in
your movie.
Sometimes you know,
you,
you hear these stories,
a lot of stories,
steven seagal,
but just people walking on eggshells
around,
you know,
whoever the,
and when you have people like mark and
rose were really cool and just really
easy to deal with everybody.
Everybody just is so much more relaxed
and having a really good time when,
you know.
And then,
I mean,
you know,
I'll take some credit for it myself too
because john and I tried to run a really
happy set and we just try to have
definitely,
man,
definitely you guys are so like you guys
are low maintenance types,
you know,
like you're like the type of people like
it feels I took you for just to show you
how unpretentious he is.
When I got the part I was like,
I,
we'd been speaking about the part and
other things and then you know,
I'll get an email about rehearsal at
paramount and I would just call sean,
like the director director.
I'm like,
hey,
is rehearsal at 10?
And he's like,
uh,
yeah.
And I'm like,
where do I park?
And he's like,
I think in the,
there's a lot that they'll tell you
they'll to go and I'm like,
okay,
and then hang up.
And I'd be like,
I'm just calling the director of like a
major picture.
Like where do I park?
And he was never fucking figure it out,
you know,
he was just like,
yeah,
it's fine.
Just call me if you need parking
directions.
It's really fun.
When is this?
Is it out right now?
Comes out friday.
Comes out just for our 16th.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
I think we can wrap this.
That was great.
Yeah.
Thank you man.
Thank you.
Thanks for doing this.
Thanks for making the movie.
Thanks for everything.
Thanks for hiring my friend.
Thanks for by the way,
I wanted to tell you before we,
before we cut out that video that you
did share that you were talking about
before of the little girl.
Got a little girl when that,
when that went out,
we were in this process of discussing,
you know,
the movie and and how to kind of get the
message out on the movie and I got that
video.
I saw it on your thing and I immediately
sent it to everybody associated with the
movie and I was like,
you guys,
this is our movie.
It's right here in this video.
It's right here and that girls face.
That's it.
That's our movie.
Wow.
That was really helpful.
I'm glad you sent that out.
Oh,
I could not.
When I got ahold of that video was so
intense.
It was so amazing.
I know.
You were trying to.
Oh no,
no worries,
man.
No,
I'm a instant family out friday.
Go see it.
You go see it.
Bye everybody.
Thanks.